and welcome back everybody to the deejay
and chess comm online Nations Cup we're
getting set here for rounds 7 & 8 and
we're getting closer and closer to
finding out who will be the two teams
competing on the day of Sunday Mother's
Day is coming up it will be the super
final the top two teams duking it out to
double their money and as we preview
rounds 7 & 8 & get the show started
let's bring on my partner in crime
grandmaster robert hess as he's chomping
at the bit here to remind everybody why
don't we start off at the top what
exactly is the online Nations Cup Robert
well that's not what I was looking for
with reminding people of but I surely
will do just that and the all Asians Cup
there are six teams from four countries
in one continent Team Europe and then a
team from the rest of the world and we
have $180,000 in prizes and it's the
first ever online event of its kind
can't wait to to see what ends up
happening in this event especially for
able to make it an annual thing it'll be
more and more historic to see who can
defend their title but let's remind
everybody of how those six teams got
here they were invited it is a double
round-robin event and just like
traditional team matches it's two point
for two points for a match win one point
for a draw zero points obviously for a
loss the super final as we said coming
up on Sunday you saw the standings
briefly there for a second and we'll
talk about it more and more obviously
throughout the day but if it's a tie
then the the winner from the double
round-robin has just declared the winner
the time controlled twenty five minutes
plus a ten-second increment and of
course there are four players playing
each time so really each team has six
players with a couple of alternates and
a captain but four players competing in
each round so let's talk about the
standings get ready here we're only a
few minutes away as usual we got to
start talking about the chess pretty
soon robber but you know it's team China
team China team China Marsha Marsha
Marsha right now at the top for everyone
else in the Brady Bunch here but Team
Europe and Team USA is getting more and
more exciting to see the race there of
course Russia not really out of it I
mean I think it's fair to say that India
and and and the world are probably not
going to be dancing on Sunday right but
everybody else still has a chance at
this point
the bottom three teams are pretty much
mathematically eliminated or if not now
they will be after one more round but
you look at the top of the standings and
you're right it's all team China thus
far the spearheaded by ding Li Ren on
board one been a very solid performer
winning a couple games drawing the rest
and you yang Jie has been a star for
that team and then you look down in
second place I mean the way Levon
Aronian has been playing as of late is
just instrumental to that team success
and of course Maxime but Sherlock Rob
had that last second grinded out victory
over yonder pom mache when the latter
aired he made tough end game of Queen
and pawn verse two rooks so many games
yesterday we could talk about we could
just do our own highlights show right or
or videos on it but there's been a lot
of instruction a lot of craziness of
course we had an amazing miniature by
Vichy and on and then a very classy
tweet from yon who just kind of
acknowledged it was a tough day for him
yesterday so we'll see if the Russian
number one can bounce back but there's a
lot that goes into what makes each of
these teams successful and as we look at
the players and how they're performing
on the boards you start to put a little
more emphasis on what went indicate the
captain's choosing those players to be
there and that brings us to our daily
question today it makes it makes us
wonder have been discussing you know the
idea to put Magnus not Magnus Carlsen
the idea to put Hikari Nakamura on board
one and Fabiano car one on more to the
idea to put you young Yee on board three
right a lot of these things are what the
captains are thinking about and maybe
maybe we'll have a captain to discuss to
discuss this with at some point before
the event is over
of course Gary Kasparov looking good
right now for his pick of Levon Aronian
on the team yeah he is for sure and you
know if you didn't already appreciate
his prowess as a chess player at
captaining to his resume and well it
must be hard for Viswanathan Anand being
player and a captain but as we look
forward to the round that's about to
happen with team China taking on Team
Europe that is the matchup to keep your
eyes on because China in first place
Europe and second your can even join
them in a tie for first with a match
victory or team China can give the rest
of the team to chance here by knocking
off Team Europe and if say you team the
USA team or Team Russia they'll have a
new found confidence going forward
yeah and of course if Europe wins that
and we have a tie for first that would
be also be a crazy crazy way to bring us
to the weekend Team India and team world
are of course battling out unfortunately
at the bottom of the standings but that
doesn't make the games any less exciting
we will have an on vs. 4 job off
goosh Rafi vs. all erisa firoozeh gonna
be awesome stuff Hari Krishna of course
taken on Jorge Cory and others
Team USA vs. Team Russia this is a big
one here obviously you know and upon me
she wants to strike back he gets another
game now against the car Nakamura one
where he pushed too far early in the
event and ultimately lost a game for
Team Russia so I don't know that we
expect that to happen again but Yan is
on a bit of a downward spiral and it'll
need it'll need to turn around first
thing this morning if Russia is gonna
stay in the chances to finish in one of
the top two places so the games I'm told
are only only about 180 seconds out
that's a fancy way to say three minutes
so we're gonna take a very very quick
break Robert when we come back we're
gonna be diving into the moves here
rounds 7 & 8 today ahead for the feed HS
calm online Nations Cup
[Music]
and we are back here getting set for
rounds 7 & 8 those will be the games
covered today and these will be the
players probably playing in both in both
rounds Robert as you spy the board ones
getting set to throw down here anything
pop out to you well of course return
often on ins chin always does because I
get this angle and Hikaru Nakamura new
bookshelf looking spiffy because he
added a few things there but on a
serious note these flares are so
excellent and you look at Dingley Ren
you look at Maxine by Sheila Grove that
is such a vital matchup to both their
team successes Levon Aronian had won
three straight games at some point so we
were giving him a lot of credit as he
deserved but Maxine foster lagron
the leader of your team taking on all of
these superstars on the top board I
thought you were gonna point out that
that looks like Yale has shaved actually
so things were not going well and Yann
is uh Yanis looking clean-shaven and
fresh today to throw down against a card
on Kimora to start things off he's gonna
need to be in his finest form because
after yesterday's debacle two losses one
a miniature one being ground down in
over 100 moves he needs some fortune to
go and aside and maybe a new look will
help his cause yeah that's John tweeted
it was a bit of bad luck too right he
ran into some ten-year-old prep by Vishy
Anand that I mean that happens as much
as it looks ugly right I guess it does
happen from time to time and when we
have tons of respect for Vichy and he's
T in his team of seconds especially as
the prep they prepared for World
Championship matches ten years ago
Robert apparently still relevant right
and then you've got a really tough game
against MDL where he defended
brilliantly and unfortunately came up
just short so again an interesting
storyline talking about about Yan but
because he is such a talented guy one of
those leading the feed a candidates at
the halfway point it's definitely been a
focus and and if he turns it around will
that be what team Russia needs to turn
around their fortunes here in the last
couple days of this event so it starts
right there as we said Hakkar Nakamura
with the white pieces against yun upon D
XI and that'll obviously be a big foe
of ours as the round gets going today
will flash the others of course from
this particular matchup our Timmy of
getting the white pieces against Bobby
on a car wanna Wesley so gets the first
move against Sergey Karjakin
and then the fourth and final board has
not gotten underway yet but there it is
we have garage kena vs. Irene a crush so
that is the USA versus Russia matchup
where else to go
we can talk about the top board between
Europe and China I mean really this is
the this is the matchup for the top of
the standings Robert and this board one
matchup is gonna have a lot of our focus
here yeah and you look at the pawn
structure already from Maxine by Sheila
Grubb he's locked in his LightSquared
Bishop with his pawn chains from d7 to
d5 and f7 to d5 so it all comes down to
this d5 square which is a nice essential
point in the position stopping white
from playing efore maybe a night jump
from black tee for anyway but that
Bishop on c8 doesn't really have air to
breathe and there multiple options here
including b6 and eventually developing
your Bishop to the Queen side or playing
for pawn to e5 at the right moment so
that's not going to be so easy with this
Bishop on b2 pawn on d4 9 f3 all staring
at that square it's interesting you
mentioned the knight on e4 right I mean
does deflect consider playing a move
like this before the bishop comes to d3
yes for sure and you gain space by
playing 94 of course on the downside you
make it double pawns in the center that
aren't so easy to protect right I was
wondering if you I mean it seems pretty
early obviously you risk a lot when you
start having to play moves like f5 to
hold on to the pawn but as MBL was
giving pause here to think about where
he wants to go like you said all other
plans are a little bit slower and he
does play Knight B to d7 we expect
Dingley run to play Bishop to d3 here so
this was an interesting interesting move
order not a mainline d 4e 4 game already
ready I guess by by the technical ec o
some sort of English opening and we see
Dingley random et playing Bishop d3 so
there will no longer be any questions
about 94 all right well I kind of want
to head back to the Hikaru
Jana Pawnee she game because it's not
just a heavy heavyweight matchup
obviously huge for USA in Russia but now
it's going to be
another very interesting Grunfeld hey
Carlo playing the night a for the nod
and young variation doing that yeah you
if you know the name of this opening but
then you cheated inside on chesnic on
didn't you know actually in fact I have
a lot of very personal stories not in
Yelland was my personal chauffeur in
Moscow when I spent a summer there
taking me back and forth from Deaver s
Keyes apartment to our norm tournament
and I spent a lot of time talking about
this opening well I take it back you are
not actually so I appreciate the call
out because it led to an interesting
story but no indeed not anyon invented
this line a long time ago and the whole
point everybody is you're avoiding all
main lines of the grünfeld where black
is gonna capture and then induce
pressure here with the typical kind of
c-5 break but 9004 says i'm losing a
tempo but that's cuz I want to play E
for as soon as I can but what is
surprising is this move Robert this is
not the standard approach 'if I've
immediately bind upon me she I don't
know what's going on anymore
well you've wasted time and putting your
984 and part of it is to avoid trades as
you mentioned also you stop any line of
c-5 because your nights and a for but
playing a five is suggesting hey your
nights off sides on the edge of the
board you've spent two moves developing
that night there and now I can play nice
see six go right back after that II five
pawn is black and continue my
development to leave and you're not only
for at some point will have to come back
into the game you know rush to do so but
that offside night doesn't look so good
for a white and so if I can rip open the
center what's your night doing on the
queenside
yeah and I'm wondering if there are
other ideas to the bishop going away
from a traditional Grunfeld development
is that is that an idea given that
White's King is open and as you said
White has wasted in fact as we say it
it's play time I'm obviously the
position will be met by Bishop TD to I
don't think there's any other move yep
hey Karim plays ed I'm a hundred percent
on on my own as as I would almost guess
I mean there's no way he is but I would
almost guess that yon also having to at
least recall opening theory he doesn't
have on the top of his brain just by
looking at his clock management
it's a dangerous position to play as
black when you you know aren't sure what
to do because it Carl this one a card
does exceptionally well is he sees a
game the day before just like he did
with Vichy I know Vichy had the upper
hand against him in their game yesterday
but he saw it Vichy did against England
said I'm gonna make a little bit of
adjustment and I'm gonna try to play
four more and that is what makes the
cars to dangerous player in addition to
his tenacity and his speed but you see
this opening clearly on caught off guard
you're not in tip-top shape and so he
plays Queen e7 protecting the bishop
going up to e5 pawn and encourage
responses here are relatively
straightforward and so young will need
to prove that either he has enough
compensation for the pawn or as you see
him do now he's going right after that
pawn
trying to recapture it but then you
split the board in half you see White's
four on three majority once the e5 pawn
drops and black them in has the three on
two and the Queen side but with the
theme kettle pawn structure some
potentially weak dark squares in the
Kings side that is what it cars aiming
for on that Southport yeah this is and
this is not gonna be your typical
grünfeld Knight b6 played immediately
the capture occurs and the question is
does white have time oh I thought it
would be Queen c3 but Queen ofor maybe
even better Robert because it stops
Bishop c4 right if Queens played perhaps
I don't know if this is workable right
away because I thought maybe you'd have
e6 but either way this this might try to
undermine the protection so interesting
stuff but again hikaru playing super
quickly saw coming in to chat it Carla
looks bored I don't think Hikaru gets
bored when he plays against other other
super grandmasters but but he definitely
looks a little relaxed it might just be
a little early for murder car oh this
point is
going to be kept much longer because you
can't actually protect it with another
piece you have the queen of the night
that's it
so rook a 5 is an idea castling and
plague rook e8 eventually but just as we
saw Vichy on and do to Jana pom she you
have to be on the lookout for some kind
of time the Queen age 695 so the
configuration as your king will be
vulnerable without a dark square bishop
protecting those squares around the
black king side yeah
well interesting stuff either way again
it started out with this obscure or less
well-known variation of the Grunfeld but
now we're getting getting a position
that we'll probably get back to being a
little more normal a little more tame
when the e5 pawn eventually Falls
probably white maintains a tiny edge
heading into a lot of the end games and
and we'll see where it goes or we'll see
if one of these guys has prep that goes
even deeper than we expect so alright
let's let's back up a little bit and we
can take a view at some of the other
potential games so many options I kind
of want to go to board 3 of this
particular matchup USA in Russia we've
got so vs. Corey Aachen also kind of a
weird opening
well you know by the pond structure it's
coming from a Spanish where white one
yes should to be five and Bishop takes
c6 because you see the material
imbalance black has a light squared
Bishop white has an extra night in the
position and the pawn Center that's
what's sort of critical at the moment is
you see a d4 pawn you see an e4 pawn
you'd like that for white but what you
don't necessarily like for white is the
fact this pawn efore there's a rook on
the lined up against it so it will
require some defense at some moment
black and because it applied pawn to c5
to challenge white center or
alternatively play Knight to d6 develop
your light square bishop mediums in
chief for to e6 and then the question is
can white actually make progress or
those pawns just look pretty sitting in
the center yeah and I was also just
buying the f6 pawn I guess it's not the
not the most surprising move I mean just
given the order of the of the moves it
was needed to defend the pawn right on
e5 but then as the structure changes
that pawn on f6 looks a little more out
of place right just because you kind of
wish you could go back you also have the
potential light square so I guess white
might be looking to be getting something
quickly here before his Center becomes
the focus meaning black targeting it and
maybe try to use it to get something
aggressive here I don't know what that
looks like but what do you buy it clean
something your Queen b3 mood yeah that I
mean just a good starting move so you
have to move your king to the corner
otherwise there's a discovered check and
then rook T after King h8 rook e1 to
protect the center and one really
annoying thing and a common theme in a
position like this is if you ever played
Knight b6 Y can respond with Knight to
a5 saying your Bishop on CA is going to
stay tied to the opponent B 7 for the
time being and if not your Bishop your
rook has to slide over to b8 and either
way you're not happy that you cannot
kick my knight out from a5 because your
nighttime b6 can't be shared with a pawn
or something like that there and so my
knight is just a thorn in your side
keeping an eye on the b7 pot but I was
wondering maybe white tries for
something like e 5 in some positions to
be even more aggressive and I guess it's
just unnecessary of course the the
fantasy idea that I actually get
something like coming to have 7 probably
just you know ridiculous but ok Queen b3
not played instead rook to e1 as quickly
met by Knight to b6 and we'll see see
how so
tries to play this fishing because you
highlighted it well if you get black a
few moves Bishop g4 the knight is
undermined
for as weak the Queen just plays natural
natural moves and the pressure comes to
the pawn so
this is uh again this will be an
interesting early stage to see who gets
the upper hand why don't we move to one
of the other matchups just because
obviously the well you know you know how
this event is we're spoiled with choices
I don't think we can lose if we pick any
battle between super GM's
we started already looking out at the
board one battle of Europe and China
maybe we go check out Bork to Levon
Aronian versus Wei Yi let's do it and
when we get to this position we see a
very weird position look at these pawns
for white advanced and forcing this
Knight out to the be Foursquare and with
white LaVon has played Bishop to d2
hitting the knight on before but I'm
looking at tactics already on the b2
squared that's what's worrying me about
this position the bishop on g7 on a
great diagonal looking to move that
night out the way and get to the b2 pond
but it looks like you're not in time
because you're not before it's already
under attack I mean playing Knight takes
D 3 check Queen takes D 3 you don't have
a good discovery move to get your Bishop
attacking that pawn on B - you'd have to
sacrifice your knight but then at the
end of those variations white gets two
minor pieces for a rook I know it's a
little bit complicated but at the end
here you protect your hook through the
bishop and then two men of peace is a
big attack to boot on the black King
eventually so that would be a good
transition for white yeah and if you
don't do if you don't go for this
transition white will play Bishop to see
free anyway and just sort of naturally
challenged it it's almost like the idea
you pointed out of fishy knowns Bishop
d2 against yonder pond me she's grünfeld
from yesterday not the same structure
but interesting to see the early advance
of d5 and e4 the bishop excuse me coming
to c3 here so but black does have a
chance to win the bishop here and can do
so I mean maybe just a simple trade and
then focus on other natural moves d6
eventually you have Sicilian ideas
expanding on the Queen side black black
looks to be doing okay other than his
connection right there again Wei Yi
rocking some bad Wi-Fi at his home
Internet yeah and actually d65 ie6 you
know and after trading on d3 looks
reasonable for black and a chisel at
this annoying white center that is quite
advanced and oh you can eat soon I'm
thinking okay interesting
Oh d6 then e six ah okay got it
but maybe e6 first is okay as well you
know I'm not positive but the point is
that if you can play e6 take on d5 open
up some light scores for that Bishop one
c8 you know the only player with the
light square bishop but at the moment it
doesn't have a good diagonal to work
with so by trading some ponds that will
help out the bishop scope
yeah okay well interesting and way ye on
the clock trying to decide his best
approach here this is board two of the
current heavyweight matchup going on
between China and Europe there you see
it on the lower left side of the
standings those two teams currently in
first and second in the event board
three for these two respective teams is
you young ye versus yon Christophe Duda
now this is uh this is an interesting
matchup Abby you've highlighted
throughout the event Robert that one
thing the team Europe hasn't really
figured out we were talking about our
daily question how did the team captains
choose their players and then set up
their board structure has been their
board three right it's been kind of an
underperforming board for Team Europe
and the opposite is true for you young
ye despite his underperforming webcam
actually think his webcam is excellent
because it makes quality entertainment
but you are indeed correct Danny that
for a young Christophe Duda it had for
three in general for Europe it's an
underwhelming this foreign giving garry
kasparov fits in a tough choice because
he can rely on Maxime on board one Levon
on board two and then he has to flip a
coin and decide who's playing on board
three so young Christophe Duda if he
wants his playing time holding with the
black side of this position will be
important against somebody as strong as
in shape and in you know just in good
spirits as new yangjia's and then if
you're in each gear you're watching this
game you're preparing for the next game
but if we talk about the position
specifically here it's looking fine for
black in the sense that everything is
defended but you taught 10 don't worry
can your from b7 gain some life
you know is it going to be stuck by it
like a sort of chain with you play C six
to reinforce the d5 pawn and when you do
play C six you're very solid but you're
a bit passive and you look at white
tonight on g3 is it going to go to f5 or
is that not really a threat to me it's
not a threat anytime the night goes in
that v you can play g6 and kick it out
so I think that black is is safe and
sound for the time being but I know
psychologically it can be difficult to
play when you don't have concrete ideas
and maybe are worried about being
lacking space in the future you know and
the the other question though is if
you're not settle
sitting is can you ever try to use the
the bishop protecting me for the rook on
that square to try to launch some sort
of more space on the Kings side yourself
obviously going to be for right away
probably no good the d5 font hanging a
lot of positions and you don't really
want to play c6 either to overprotect it
one because c6 is probably just met by
b5 and the whole structure is undermined
but to because it closes the bishop so
it's weird I totally agree with you
black is totally solid but also down on
the clock and definitely no I don't know
is it fair to say I'm struggling to find
the best plan for black is it as slow as
like g6 Bishop g7 9 f8 something like
that
well I think you can play c6 because if
y + b5 them then black plays c5 ok good
that's something that gives black some
play and I can't play c5 now because
then B takes e5 and the B pawn on d6 for
black is pinned because the bishop on b7
and c6 it makes sense and I think black
can play g6 me Bishop d6 pawn h5 and
play alpha zero style being more
aggressive on the King side yeah you're
talking to me you know I like that yeah
and so the question does white try to
prepare for b5 with things like rook e1
you get pressure on the D pawn so that
when that structure changes maybe you're
ready to open up and put pressure there
so interesting to see what you young he
goes for you know a fair question from
the chat Robert I wonder if you and I
are I mean remembering that Duda has
been worse in a few games someone said
why are we seeing him as underperforming
when he's won a game and drawn the rest
he hasn't actually lost in the event
right and I guess our view was he was
definitely close to losing I mean he
should have lost a pentile Hari Krishna
for sure and we still don't even know
how that we never went back to that I
don't know how we got out of that game
but but I guess maybe that's one of
those where you and I is probably know
the game's better than anybody in the
world right now cuz it's what we're
doing for this week maybe are we being a
little too harsh on the young man from
Poland maybe he is doing ok yeah he is
doing alright and his score is good he's
2 out of 3 but that is the game that
sticks out to me the most and perhaps
it's just clouding my judgment because I
think of the Hari Krishna game I'm like
he was completely lost and somehow he
survived that one I mean credit to him
right we've given other players credit
for their defense and Younker subdued Oh
showed in a tough spot
he's able to
avoid getting the donut in the
scoreboard so you gotta give him props
where they're doing they are in fact do
but I still think that kind of shaky
play will leave a team captain wondering
hey can I trust this player with the
black pieces right or should I put in a
nice giri who has more experience at the
highest level of chess right yes yeah
and I think that spirits why I've read
that comment from shadows like you know
what maybe they're right maybe maybe he
is doing okay and we do have memory if
you missed that game with Nutella Hari
Krishna where Judith had very very shaky
performance and some other games too we
were a little worried but but okay we'll
see what happens here he's going up
against the best performing board three
of the event undeniably so at you young
ye so we'll see how that goes
backing up of course so many other games
we can continue to look at if you see
one partner just yell at me like you
normally do in the in the very soft way
that you yell and let me know well I
guess some people been asking for visi
an on and tamer over job off so perhaps
perhaps that say a direction to go
bringing up that one where the game is
moving along very quickly but but
definitely an unbalanced one that's kind
of fun right you've got big Center bad
pawns for black but a bishop pair and an
a pawn to go with it so this is an
interesting one yeah this is quite a
fascinating position and I'm trying to
do a quick count because black doesn't
have a G pawn or an e pawn but black
does have six pawns two white six pawn
so it looks like black might even be
down one but it's not any well now black
is that out I'm glad we I'm glad we
clarified that a little while even Matt
actually blacks down upon and and
where's the compensation the
compensation comes in the form of clumsy
Knights for white so I would not take on
a 5s for sure because if you take on a
five that Knight wants a head right into
c6 even if it costs you a pawn or
doubles your pawns because you know the
Knights not doing any I would play
Bishop to d7 and then try to swing my
forces to the Queen side as black you
know either a queen or a rook to b8 and
maybe if you my Queen doesn't going to
be a go to f6 and the bishops are very
powerful not because there's necessary
weakness to exploit but because the
Knights don't have protection so you can
kick the Knights around for a couple
again sometime and if you can seize the
initiative really quickly maybe a pawn
like the one on c4 can become a target
okay and that's highlighting the you
know the glasses have full approach for
black right the glasses have 2 MP
approaches black is down upon and and
while he does say I was gonna say white
if you didn't take it is gonna bring the
other rook over at some point and try to
force this way through so he trades in
them Queen g5 Wow where job off is is
saying you know maybe I need to be
all-in right now down upon and use my
bishop pair before White's Queen can
coordinate guarding both the knight and
the potential weak King side so it's
it's a pretty looking move that looks
like a move that I would play but I
don't know that it has any substance to
it if white play something like h3
where's the where's the concrete attack
here I guess f5 is coming right I mean
and that's gonna be a way to get more
activity more open lines yes I think
exactly what you're predicting will
happen with h3 followed by f5 and as is
in the Kings Indian defense you say I'm
going all in for an attack on the White
King and then your Queen side is black
might collapse but you're hoping that
the attack is potent enough but after h3
f5 I'm considering capturing on f5 and I
know you'll take with your bishop that
looks good for black what if I just go
Knight b5 like can I just become greedy
and start stealing your pawns on the 19
side and man are you ready to highlight
that move I'm not used to this greedy
robber here like I want like nice c6 or
but ok I mean heck here we go right as a
commentator right we can always take the
moves back vision and cannot so if he
gets attacked and is losing well that's
the problem for him but for us he's good
to explore this because what is going
for this all-in approach right what if
white just says hey I'm not scared let
me take your pieces as commentators it
is easy to take to take moves back it's
also easy to do the conversation toward
a lot of people have been wondering
throughout the event maybe that should
have been our daily question what
exactly is teh more of a job of drinking
I think it's cranberry juice and the
light plays tricks but maybe I'm being a
little too PG on that I'm not getting
involved in that discussion I'll leave
that to your speculation yeah alright
well we'll we'll continue to wonder fans
what exactly is teh more drinking who
knows and let us know if you if you do
know if you do know please let us know
alright again Robert I'm spying a lot of
games of course we have some huge
matchups going on this round everybody
if you're not happy with where we're
covering please go to chess comm slash
live but actually know the manual way
not even needed to describe just go to
go chess comm slash ONC games that link
will take you and automatically follow
all the games you need so not too hard
and if you're on the go remember you can
also watch on your mobile phone whether
it's Android or a mobile device or
Android or mobile Android or mobile
Robert it's early
where you want to go buddy um I don't I
don't know I'm actually just looking
through the games myself trying fair
let's go to the game between Alexander
Goryeo Chicana and Irina cross because
we might not have a chance to come back
to it maybe we will and maybe I'm
speaking too soon but I saw that there
are not many pieces on that board here
and Irina cross where the black piece is
trying to fend off the Women's World
Championship challenger from earlier
this year
and I mean I like White's position
that's for sure you're more active than
item D eights of passive piece compared
to the knight on c5 but is there really
enough to break through here de what do
you think no I mean that's I was
wondering where your tone was going with
why we wouldn't have the time to come
back to it I assume you might be
thinking it's gonna be a draw soon
because I didn't think that white really
has enough to go to go full steam
although when you look at the position
its garage King uh on the clock you'd
love to figure out a way to undermine
the bishop in the center I mean is that
f3 and he for I think II for right away
let met by Bishop takes e5 so an
intermezzo that the wins the pawn you
can't do that but yeah I mean I'm with
you that it doesn't seem like a position
that's super dangerous for black which
okay if that's the case I think that's a
super successful result for Team USA
and actually I don't see Irina in her
chair so I'm curious where she might be
right now but no problem just refreshing
using the bathroom I don't know the
players there that's not usually your
thing to speculate on that so you know
oh there she is
she's matter she's back well she's been
great for USA on board for she's yeah so
yeah so black found her rhythm and and
in huge in large part been have been a
big reason for their success obviously
they're they're in third place still
trailing both Team Europe and team China
in that particular order they're reverse
reverse order but go ahead no I still
like whites position 97 is one of those
annoying moves because are you trying to
go night to be six and played a 4 and be
five eventually I mean I don't know the
exact plan here but it just feels like a
move that stops my King from getting
towards the center so black perhaps
should think about f5 and King of 7 to
get the King closer but f5 has your own
sorts of problems with the e5 square now
being permanently under White's control
so I don't think black has solved this
yet but I do think that objectively the
position is closer to balance that any
significant edge for white okay well uh
garage kina has the experience to be
able to convert on a game like this even
if it is a small edge so maybe that's
the other way to look at it just that
she she wants to get a grind it out game
where maybe she feels that she's
comfortably playing for two results
recently the Challenger to the world
championship title in women's chess she
came up short against you in June but
obviously a a huge star and probably
will be there again for other matches in
the future if I had to guess so alright
we'll keep an eye on this I'm again
spying there's a lot of exciting games
this round one that is not going to be
super exciting so speaking of touching
in on it before it ends quickly let's go
over to her Coronel Kimora's game with
Jana pom Nishi and I know here Caro has
has a small edge here based on the pawn
structure but just I guess assuming I
shouldn't do that but given the nature
of the major piece and games I'm
expecting a peaceful result in this one
if one thing I'd be concerned about is
preps blacks King safety you know I
still the loose dark squares in front of
the black King can present a problem and
this rook and Queen already lined up on
the D file so isn't there some kind of
rook da tore up d7 in a timely manner
but yeah I do think ultimately you're
right that with so many trades and so
few pieces remaining on this board that
as liquidation continues to occur even
if all three pawns there for black are
traded for whites to Queen side pawns
yeah and if say the Queen's get traded
in the process the four on three there's
so many theoretically drawing rook end
games that you have to consider yeah
that's partly why I was also thinking
that it would be likely a peaceful
result it's almost like in some of these
end games you'd like to keep the major
pieces on the board and fantasized about
the Queen and rook doing nasty things
over here on the eighth-ranked but
blacks pieces are coordinated well
enough likely that's just not gonna be
the case and if you keep the Queen's on
the board that the reverse might be true
I mean black can bring the cleanup and
maybe the C pawn combined with some
threats over here on the Kings side get
a little scary for her car right so most
likely we don't see that kind of risk
taken and and this is probably a
peaceful results so okay that means
it'll come down the other games I guess
one of the only matchups between Team
USA and Team Russia we haven't really
checked on is the board to battle let's
head over to Fabiano car Juana's
defensive effort here as black versus
Vladislav Artemyev chuck norris of
russian chess is what vladislav is
called i have no idea why but we go with
it because if alexander grishnack says
it's a nickname that it's a nickname and
there he is vladislav our timmy of the
the Chuck Norris of Team Russia and what
a position this is because you see a
light squared Bishop versus a knight and
you see that black has a ton of light
score pawns which means that the bishop
on d3 doesn't have a great diagonal to
work with that said there's a black King
on e7 and a white King on d2 so both
Kings in the center of the board white
controlling the game's only open file so
I think if you have to give any player
an advantage for the moment it's white
but perhaps if the game continues and
you look at our Tamia's clock
if Fabiano can you know lash out at the
right moment especially as this white
King goes on a journey then perhaps
their chances for fraud
you know to play for more than just a
half-point yeah it's one of those
positions that's double-edged enough
with the imbalance of the night and
Bishop and like you said both Kings
potentially being weird that it's it
could be it could be three results still
for sure
so if Vlad Aslaug doesn't doesn't use
the a file correctly what it what is the
plan here for white hard to think of one
yeah black is looking super solid here I
don't know what the plan is so weird
position right like why do you think the
computers slightly favored white in a
position where black is just super solid
is it just biased toward the bishop
versus the night I mean I'm liking black
as well on a structural level I like
black long-term open file all right I
think the open file is white for the
taking and if you play rook a7 I can
take on a7 your seasick actually that's
a hilarious almost Queen trap there it
is a queen trap so you can play Brooke
day seven here because after instead of
Knight to b5 because if you took on a
seven it took on c6 rook state would
have trapped the Queen
just show that real quick cuz it's fun
big stakes Jake and bake and the queen
goes bye-bye
okay umm night be five plate instead the
Queen backs up quickly to the a file and
of course capturing probably not ideal
when you're opening up a see file to hit
c2
right and even though you double isolate
black spawns white actually has the
pawns that are easier to attack there
and you're giving black very important
space so you know now you can consider
taking on b5 at any moment the Knights
not going anywhere I can go back to d6
but then you ask what's in Black Pearl
again I think it's what you're gonna see
is just sort of shuffling from the time
being neither side coming up with
anything concrete hey Black Ice King out
fades get the King out of the center
yeah I'm just not seeing much for either
side okay the time pressure is well not
not relevant yet but it definitely
favors Caruana up almost ten minutes on
the clock so in an otherwise equal game
where there may be some sort of crazy
imbalances you start looking at time
pressure the first person down on the
clock may end up getting himself in
trouble in a self-induced way so we'll
keep an eye on that
so in karaoke no king of six I had the
same reaction we're about to switch
games and again it's kind of funny
because it made it may just be a fancy
way to put it's so funny cuz like it
really doesn't do anything besides just
like come to g7 right but it's a funny
maneuver either way
yeah that was no surprising okay so in
carjacking
reset rewind that's what that's what I
was trying to say here comes black
putting pressure on the structure and
and you kind of called it earlier I mean
like if white didn't get something
yeah and Wesley so kind of shaking his
head if white didn't get something then
it was only a matter of time before
natural developing moves put pressure
against white spots right and if you
look at the position it seems like black
didn't really do anything I mean the
Queen shifted to f7 the rooks are
centralized the bishop developed and
went back to c8 but it really doesn't
feel like black has done anything major
and yet white is in some serious trouble
here because you look at the black rooks
just barreling down at White's once
beautiful center that Center may
collapse at any moment and if you play a
move like 'if I've well then I can take
on d4 take on e5 at some point with
Bishop on the white squares opens up and
I don't know I did at this point here
with black to move you could start with
Bishop f5 I mean the Pawnee 4 is pinned
and I wouldn't mind putting pressure on
that square
yet if the bishop relocates to g6 it
probably isn't any worse for it given
that it was on c8 and it gets to keep
putting pressure on the center
khari alkanes super-focused there Wesly
enjoying some oatmeal his favorite
morning snack no but we sell him shaking
his head earlier and clearly he was not
not super pleased with how the first
stage of things that went here and he
and he shouldn't be pleased because I'm
also anticipating at some moment the a
to pond
being a vulnerability as if yeah the
bishop moves off the last ranked of rook
can swing to a eight and that pawn a2 is
very importantly placed there because it
protects the pun on b3 so there's
actually some problems for white in this
pawn structure despite black being the
one with two sets of double pawns that
compact Queen side structure where black
is poking at the center it is
advantageous for crackin okay so the
trade I feel a little relief there if
I'm Wesley at least I get to bring the
knight quickly to the center but like
you said maybe Kuryakin spies that this
three-on-two and the potential pressure
on the a file is really really one of
his biggest long-term edges in the
position
and their numerous options for black you
can play Bishop d7 you could play Bishop
g4 you could start with queen h5 just to
develop your queen I made Bishop d6
after that just a spy on the White King
side and I just don't really know what
blacks that's your wife's plan is and I
just think that cardiac can has an
excellent position out of the opening
here let's head back over to another
board board - sorry well it's not a
board three battle which is what this is
forgive my confusion when you have so
many of the world's best players you
forget which board they're actually
playing on but Levon Aronian and Wei Yi
and the Europe versus China battle are
moving along quickly here and I'm
starting to like whites chances much
more than I did before and perhaps
that's a bit of an overestimation but I
looked at the D pawn and spying that
little mini board preview there on chess
calm and I thought I thought why should
be better here though the King beat the
Kings a little open right so there's
definitely a double-edged double-edged
game still well that Bishop on b6 is
multitasking because it stops a black
rook from getting to d8 but it also
protects the white king and the f2
square in particular so that's a great
Bishop that's lodged in there it's gonna
camp out with the Pony v protecting it
permanently and there's nothing black
can do about it however I do agree with
you Danny that the white King side does
feel a little bit breezy there and I
don't know the exact move here maybe
rook f4 because that just gives black
more activity you can swing to the b4
square
he said doubles his rooks in the ephah
which i think is a sensible thing to do
but where are you going there I don't
see the follow up necessarily and now
actually Queen to c2 and then Bishop c5
is the third of Queen c4 you know in
these Queen moves which also allows you
if I be for next to expand further on
the Queen side and threatened to skewer
the Queen and the rook so I'm liking
lavon's position you've seen this very
often in many d4 pawn openings where you
get that past D pawn your queen is not a
good block hitter not as good as a
knight would be there necessarily and at
first I I thought Queen c4 couldn't be
as good as Queen c2 because of rook f4
but then I just started considering what
you were saying I mean maybe I can't
even go like
and if the Queens are traded you're
better in the endgame with the pasty
pawn you can reinforce the bishop there
I don't know if that's the best way to
convert the advantage but I like your
eye I like your idea of just getting the
Queen off the b3 squares so that you can
play b4 push the space maybe put a
Bishop on c5 the other thing we have to
talk about here is the clock right and
way Yi is is he's no stranger to time
for us sure I think he's impressed us at
least surprised us in regards to how
well he's handled it in other events I
mean he won the junior speeches
championship but um but being down this
much on the clock was so much to go is a
little a little concerning for team
China and it's how Levon Aronian beat
all there is a firoozeh is he just had a
better position he was grinding and
grinding and running and finally the
defense's broke in time troubles so if
you are a team Europe fan and if you're
a Levon Aronian fan how could you not be
impressed with the way he's been playing
after that opening round loss -
Vladislav Artemia which still may be the
game of the tournament by Artemia but
since then Aronian has been nothing
short of spectacular ya know and uh the
the team europe in many ways is is I
mean it's undeniably being led by Levon
Aronian right now of course MBL on board
one is is a given kind of a thankless
task I like a car Nakamura on board once
you say it's a tough thing but what's
but it's tough on any board and LaVon
has gotten the job done
we're being yelled out in the chat that
the game between you young ye and young
Christopher Duda is spicing up speeding
up whatever you want to call it it's
getting messy and white on the attack
over here on the Kings side but black
has already broken through over here on
the queenside b4 looks like it's hanging
but I know that's a point you can take
Robert here comes Knight here comes
Bishop here come here come the problems
over here to the Kings side
I mean you yeah he was hanging his head
you think he's really impressing me
Danny and just what can else can you say
the guy is just playing lights out chess
right now and actually quite literally
lights out because I don't know what's
going on with that web cam is it I think
you keeps flickering over there but look
at this King side attack that he is
unleashing on young Christoph dude his
King as I said Knight h5 is a threat
after which you can play 19 g7
the knight there to just blast open the
King this night at c3 can come to e4 and
into the f6 square because the g7 pawn
is pin and after Knight takes before I
think the immediate response has to be
Knight h5 because the bishop on f8 is
overworked it is protecting the g7
square with check and mate it's also
protecting the knight over here on b4 so
after Knight h5 you give me one free
moving plank rook takes before with a
free piece not to mention 90 to g7 with
Bishop h6 or f6 to follow I I think that
White has to crash through and just the
next few moves well we saw y'all we saw
young Christoph shaking his head when we
first brought the board up and given
that he's my it just seems much worse
and only 3 minutes to solve a ton of
problems coming his way this looks like
it will be oh he goes rook takes before
immediately whoa rook a3 responded
immediately look this is crazy it's
getting confusing that's for sure and
after rook a3 I mean can he just wait a
time your move earlier was was kind of
good when you were threatening rook
takes before now that you've already won
the piece you could also play 94-year
wait the bishops hanging so that's what
what an interesting response and
actually maybe Brooke takes d4 was a
blunder we see young Christoph getting a
little bit of life back in his face and
if we if we back up your move Knight age
5 was definitely what the doctor ordered
and one of the main differences Robert
is that is that rook a3 just doesn't
work cuz of the aforementioned Knight
takes g7 and it's matin baked over here
so crazy that taking before Bishop takes
before would have been losing and maybe
that's what you young he just expected
that there was no other choice but to go
for something like this where it's check
made but JKD shocks the world with this
crazy rook to a3
and I don't believe in Adeiny I know
it's crazy I didn't expect it I still
think that what has to be winning but
these are the type of moves that you
play you confuse your opponent and you
know in a game where you Aeneas plenty
of time he should be able to work this
one out so let's just think take them a
step back because when you get shocked
you have just big I I know my position
is good I have an attack what come moves
come to mind Knight age five still comes
to mind going for that attack that you
we've been discussing Knight gd4
potentially because Bishop takes before
there's Bishop h6 guys so going for that
same checkmating attack it just happens
me with the bishop instead of the night
and you know actually how your second
seven good
so I I see 6f6 you have so many
attacking options for white that I can
see it going wrong but with you Yankee
playing the way he has all event I think
he is gonna be able to handle okay we're
okay three I didn't even think about
that move on that side of the board but
it doesn't actually ultimately save
blacks position
yo I'm kind of fascinated by the tactics
but I'm liking your night gu4 move more
and more just as a way to guard c3 and
threaten Bishop h6 it makes makes enough
sense right and this is one of the
positions where a human calculating deep
might even see the winning idea before a
computer ok he already plays Knight g4
but a human might even see it before a
computer does cuz humans are more
readily to sacrifice pieces and forget
the math first and think about it second
for checkmate and I think I think you
yongi will probably deliver something
nasty to bring this game to a close this
is this is again what team China
planned all along I guess well Danny
it's funny because we love sacrificing
people's pieces yeah I suggested Knight
GTE for just so I wouldn't have to
sacrifice all the pieces I was like
let's just be calm for a second and
acknowledge that Bishop takes before
that's a rook that is hanging what seems
like for free but checkmate supersedes
material and submission before Bishop h6
Annie let's say go g6 instead of Bishop
f8 because we saw a distinction just
look at the dark squares we've talked
about this a lot the Fein keto pawn
structure no Bishop to be on the g7
square Knight f6 check followed by Queen
h4 and just you can use mommy just start
taking everything and I don't even know
back everything and we just said we
weren't going to do that and then you
just I just think it's probably good
enough and I you know you said it's not
my pieces no but this looks super
dangerous again young Kristoff already
getting under two minutes in a really
tough spot but you know everybody's been
in a tough spot against China so so we
we feel for them right again still a ton
of games going in this round another
game going on in the China versus Europe
matchup is if you win June and Ani moot
on a musii Chuck former women's world
champion and the current Women's World
Champion
wait no you confused me Maria Lucy Chuck
is the former women's world champion
this is all your fault I did make that
mistake I admit it you know I normally
don't when it comes to you watching
things but I did at first
and with the white piece is on a mu Z
Chuck you know she has a sister who's
playing on the team for the rest of the
world but right now without white pieces
it's an end game with just a rook minor
piece and five pawns aside and to say
who's better is the bishop better than
the knight and to me it's not really
about that just yet it's about the
activity of black's rook yeah compared
to the defensive nature of white's rook
and there's one really committal
decision that I'm not sure that I want
to play a c4 for a black because it
limits the bishops scope and forces the
bishop back to f1 because you can't
afford my work going into e2 after a
black play c4 and I'm just not sure that
it's good because then my d5 pawn
becomes this target that's sort of stuck
in place so that's if I'm being cautious
I just maybe play a King e6 and rookie 5
and I'm worried and I put word in quotes
so that just Peters out and why he's
able to hold by trading pieces so if
you're playing ambitiously you play a
move like c4 if you're just playing hey
I'm slightly better but I don't want to
take any risks and my team doesn't need
me to win then I just play move like
King e6 or pretty much any other move
yep
I think I think that blacks should
probably still be the only one who can
window so why not play for two results
more aggressively I think your idea of
c4 you could even swing back to the B
file and put pressure on b2 I just don't
see how quickly white gets pressure to
d5 which is the main risk of playing c4
is like if the bishop could go to e 2
and F 3 that might be a problem but how
do you do that you can't go to yeah I
guess your confidence is renewing my
confidence in the plan and you the black
king can just come to e6 an important
white never has time to play g4 g5 to
dislodge this Knight from like c4
because even okay this isn't even
possible because the bishop thing but I
was sitting here trying to figure out
like even in something like this like
where you get pressure on b2 you're
still getting b2 and guarding d5 long
before white and again that's it's not
even a possible variation so c4 is what
the doctor ordered mu Z Chuck does have
to retreat the bishop and big surprise
you when Jun doing fantastically here on
board for for China and the question now
becomes how do you win a position like
this as black I mean she starts with
rookie 7 she's maybe uh eyeing the b7
square for her rook trying to hit b2 but
then white can just put a rook in the
second rank and say I am solid here you
can't put any more pressure just yet and
if I am on a mu Z Chuck my first move
here is b3 I am not allowing you to make
my rook a pass a piece play b3 and say
well I'm just trading pawns here we're
whittling this one down and I don't
think white is in that much danger so
maybe I overestimated the c-4 move or
perhaps black retreated her rook too
soon because it allows white to play b3
I was gonna say you were treating the
rook seems like the problem because III
was not a possibility until until she
did I mean your your your good
old-fashioned King e6 looked good
right Kim temple I'm like this now I
guess b3 would have been stopped by 94
checks oh okay well we'll see if mu Z
check comes up with b3 I think it's a
perfect perfect whoa she doesn't and she
may not get another chance after it rook
to b7 but this is this is an interesting
move to write she wants to play g5 and
put the bishop on g2 - you get pressure
on the d5 backward pawn yes and this one
you know it's going I think be a bit
more of a struggle but Dani I'm looking
at the chat and we must go to the game
with you hard Christian and Jorge Cory
because I see people praying that our
Christian does not make another mouse
slip because look at his position here
because it would take a mouse slip for
him to lose this game and again if you
didn't see that yesterday one of the one
of the moments that didn't get a lot of
play because there was some amazing just
actual chess on the board but one of the
worst things that happened was was Hari
Krishna loses a game with a single mouse
slipped the first and only mouse lip of
the event as far as we know
so Hari Krishna looking to bounce back
forget that one you could at least be
happy that he's played some really great
chess he just hasn't converted for Team
India I mean he was completely winning
against young Christopher Duda should
have drawn easily yesterday they've had
some bad luck but maybe Hari turns it
around here well the f6 pawn is just I
mean you're putting all your pieces all
your pressure on that square and so now
the king is in check you have to move
the King away and then there's Rudy de
f1 next move and blacks position is
really bad here and for Jorge Cory you
knew that every match is going to be a
tough one for him as it is for everybody
else but this King is in trouble
Hari is ready to pounce and just the
bind structure that we see in the
position with the e4 and see if four
pawns it's not like black has any
counter play whatsoever and very
importantly into this position it's
going to be a swift attack yeah I mean
and the concrete threats of the other
rook just coming to f1 looks looks rough
feels bad man feels bad
there's also Bishop h3 coming so the one
saving grace black has is this Knight
comes to c5 and maybe you find some way
to
Aksum material but you get the four pawn
who knows you swindle your ass is
falling too quickly Danny so yeah it's
just I mean the King moves and we just
bring the rook over right and f5 doesn't
help because now you're opening up my
bishop on g2 and that was going to land
somewhere that you're not going to be
happy about
uh yeah maybe d5 or b7 just 93 right
you're hitting at 5 then I can go too
deep I mean but he's better there you
know but yeah but though it's it's it's
a very good position so King h8 chosen
partly partly by Corey maybe just to
avoid the night ever coming to f6 with
Chuck I mean that makes sense just from
a practical perspective put the King on
a slightly safer Square but I see people
in the chest comm game chat meeting on
the live server just everybody's saying
don't Mouse Lipari don't mouse slip so
they know what happened yesterday oh you
know it's not a mouse in there it is
well they take c5 I was just buying that
both pawns are pinned and the Queen is
stuck to the rooks defense in the f8 and
Knight takes d5 is a great move by Hari
Krishna that is not a mistake everybody
because oh man dang Brooklyn if you type
in so well with you know what's not a
mouse slip there it is that was awesome
the move Knight takes e5 double pin
right can we get like a soundtrack of
like double kill double pin 165 not
possible either a queen e5 of course
yeah I didn't show that one cuz the
Queen of fate but wow what a move there
and clock goes bang bang nope Corrie
resigns with 0.6 seconds on the clock
not a great result there 14 worlds board
three but Hari Krishna you got to be a
little happy he's bouncing back board 2
has been drawn between our Timmy avantco
wanna from the USA vs. Russia match up
so this this one I guess not super
surprising we talked about a double
edged it was after the Kings kind of did
their did their funny dance but I think
if either side pushed too hard this is a
game that both sides could lose and so
and so they didn't looks like they
traded and very quickly settled on a
perpetual so we move on Hikaru and Yann
upon me she's speaking of the USA versus
Russia battle still going another draw
real quick just got to show it cuz it
just hit the screen on
muzie Chuck has drawn against you in
June so not a bad result there for Team
Europe especially given that she seemed
to be worse a few moves ago so good
stuff therefore musii Chuck
yes I'm free we got a team girls you
yell ye game oh my gosh
this is this is where the action is it's
I mean just looks like a mating attack
right it's it's no good by the way shout
off to young Christa for his flair look
at the little night fork Flair anyone
could show their Flair just like going
to chotchkie's right show your Flair
even if it's 37 pieces but the the Flair
of the night fork I got to love that
well I'm loving the position from the
white side of things here because f7 is
under attack
if f7 is moved or captured g6 Falls and
that King on g8 has one defender and
it's that Queen on g4 but unfortunately
a queen can't fend off in the enemy
Bishop an enemy night in a row and an
enemy Queen all the pieces aiming at the
black king and unfortunately for young
Christoph there's a not even an
opportunity to be resilient here and we
know he is because it I just don't see a
move yeah
shout to the chat world where we're
fixing the scoreboard and don't you
worry it will be awesome possum in just
a second just like you young East chess
this has been just the event for him I
mean if you had to vote for MVPs right
now you young eboard 3 notwithstanding
is gets my vote for Team China like
Hikaru for USA I think he's the only one
who's played every round if he missed
one it was only one he's playing every
round
ok Vichy Vichy as well so Vichy Hikaru
and I think you young Yi Levon Aronian
has also played just fantastic chests as
well so that might be an MVP but but
okay it's also Rajab of an envier also
played every round if I'm not mistaken
really I think so boredom hands tend not
to sit very often okay well there you go
the the move Queen b3 tries to confuse
things a little bit
because you're attacking of one
don't take one lf7 with the rook as
Queen d1 would have been made in a
couple now we're definite what's the
move Knight g5 check maybe
- I have six actually maybe - well 95
you have to take my bishop than have a
Queen h4 check and I just gone mate you
by force I get a queen f 8 equals queen
that equals Queen sassy molasse e and
it's that you do it
yeah ladies young Kristoff do you see
his face Dani yeah he shakes his head he
knows it's he knows its mate Ginga HJ
doesn't really slow it down either
you could just play f8
not really because they use take on a
fate yeah I forgot about the bishop over
here so King H a where's our knockout
here
I was gonna leave you to find that Danny
come on 100 percent what happened here
no after takes check no it is Bishop g7
oh because then the knight comes to e6
nice there you go there you go when you
have to sack people's pieces you don't
do it what's what I didn't want to I
wanted to I wanted there to be a clean
mate but Bishop g7 is a nice little way
to bring the king that's an attraction
tactic you bring the King to the square
he doesn't want to come to and then
nightly for checkup so JKD just resigns
on Bishop g7 yep because that actually
was a force checkmate a nice finish
there with a flair by you Yankee and
yeah what's yet now five and a half at a
seven I mean you have to give the MVP
nods him thus far yeah he's playing to
play an amazing chess helping to lead
team China who is leading the event
let's head back over to MBL's game with
Dingley Ren wait no it was just ended
and drawn so nevermind we leave that one
behind a lot of games coming in now and
rapid-fire Hikaru and Yana pom Nishi
still rolling along as well as Vishy
Anand and tamer job off this one looks a
little bit trickier Umbra job off down
on the clock again he's been under time
pressure for most of his games
he has and what's the material count
Black has four pawns White has five so
at least one extra pawn for white and
the g3 pawn can be captured with the
Queen's coming off I think only white
can be favored in such a position but
there aren't so many pawns remaining
that I I do believe that blacks should
have pretty good chances to survive this
one yeah to hold yeah it's hard to deal
with both the knight in the F pawn right
if you trade and you can't take with the
pawn because the knight hangs and you
can't well if you take with the knight
the F coupon hang so your job off like
you said looks like he hasn't a fresher
or we're just gonna see a queen d7
maybe some sort of perpetual here
perhaps it would be surprised if we get
a perpetual because Y can start with
night takes g3 and just say hey I mean
if you want to take mine I know g3 go
for it but after Knight takes g3 we're
I'm stealing a pawn
I should be happy about that yeah and in
this before you still guard f2 so many
games by the way you should head over to
chess calm and follow them yourself if
you're not already the Levon Aronian
wayy battle is is coming down to the
wire as well let's go over there that is
a crazy rook ending that I mean it looks
good for black just cuz the Kings are
under the king is under pressure my
first instincts hate that but the way
he's under a ton of time pressure that
the Queen side pawns are good and Bryce
rooks are very active right White's King
is in more danger for sure yeah
and now the question becomes you know
you know are white spawns too quick and
he goes rook to b3 to get behind the
pawn and I guess just rook b6 rook is
awkwardly placed cuz you
he might just trick try to go p7 check
pawn a7 pawn b6 rook to b8 but that is
very time-consuming and it feels like
black has to have a way out here with
that white King being so exposed you
know it's so funny right because the
rook on e2 is like it's like the perfect
defender it is it whole like that I'm
not gonna rank and
poor move though Danny h4
because when you play h4 you're getting
closer to the White King and you also
are protecting the g3 square so you get
a rook g3 check and the King doesn't
come out and attack that rook in some
variations you know so if you just have
to time things well but that I think is
a very very good move especially
considering that you know those a and B
pawns are looking menacing only 24
seconds for Wei Yi means he made that
move with 14 seconds on the clock with
knowing it's the 25 minute + 10 second
increment time control so that's now he
moves instantly there but here comes a 7
so I mean both sides are all in LaVon is
like well if I'm if I get made it I get
made it I guess I gotta go get a queen
yeah that's the it's funny because some
people think defending your King
requires passivity but this moment it
calls for activity you got to push your
pawns and force blacks hand here so
rook a 1 check yo Keaney g2 and me how
does well I don't see ok I don't know
every this rookie 2 is like okay if you
go to h2 then then black has the
perpetual and if King F to Mapes maybe
it's also perpetual that's why the
Vaughan plays rook g2 he doesn't want
the book of that move rook h3 is
brilliant yeah now we've got checks
coming from this side of the board and
the King can't hide behind the rook no
that's and that's an exceptional
defensive fire Wow actually I I didn't
see that coming but rook age sorry like
this I thought this was gonna blow
everybody the key is you prevent this
move King h2 so just to show you an
example if if this check comes the King
hides behind the rook with checks and
probably why it is just winning now cuz
your best attempt is just to make trades
but this move rook h3 that might be the
draw saving move we see the vaunted roni
and lean in and just like a good move
youngster wouldn't obscure dry mechanism
seriously say there's a fun one and I
don't see anything that I can do because
if you play your rook over let's say
rook to be 2 or something just get your
right go out of the way again mike has
no well black House has rook it maybe
there's that check washing rook a 1
check your King steps up and then
remember up to h1 my
- h1 oh wait now you're well you put
your king where I could check you know
it which was eating kingi - and that's
the only move and then rook a to H 1
and good luck getting out of this right
because I even get a queen if you know
rapid-fire rook g4 was met by king h5
this is one of those positions that both
sides could lose with one misstep
although I think we'll get a draw after
rook G - oh whoa wait a second
no Brooke GG was bad yeah cuz you check
and then the real comes to f3 with Chuck
indeed Wow
whoa so that was actually smart by LaVon
thereby taking the e4 pawn he gives his
Kings a way to run to the center and if
you allow me to Queen I'm gonna Queen as
white but you have so many checks in the
interim
so rook H to rook h1 checks aren't yarn
stop yeah check and check right looks
like it's about to happen check again
the King's gonna back up Oh nope live
all that just pushing this game what
Brooke 82 now rook a to and then rook gg
100 okay three is kind of the same idea
but you're threatening made immediately
actually
wait a second
let's go
Wow as we like we're rookies each for
check fortune and then Brooke age seven
you trade and be six so what black has
to do is go after rook age four you give
up your rook and then take the a seven
point at the end so you like King h4
yeah
you give it a look and then just take a
seven and offer a draw oh my gosh oh my
god that's why positions like this are
sewn as zeros by the computer even
though every human being is like white
is lost here but but rook h4 what a flip
and crazy draw is that the only move I
think it I have no I don't have any move
suggestions I just have the eval bar but
I mean I was sitting here like how is
white holding this this looks lost for
white but wrote takes h4 and I mean if
I'm being honest I can also see the eval
but I don't know the variation there it
is but I was going to say I can see the
evaluation without the variation and
that is very helpful because you know in
a position like this you're looking like
wait where is the Equality every single
move looks like it's winning for black
and then you're like oh wait a second
there has to be something equal I know
there's something there and then rook
takes h4 Czech lands on the board oh my
gosh
super-crazy rook takes h4 leans back and
I don't if you saw that LaVon just
mailed the word draw I missed that one
yeah when you've been dead when you've
been done test I've been dead for many
years now I've been deaf since my
childhood so lip-reading became a skill
yes so anyway now it's a draw wow what a
finish what a crazy way to bring a game
to a close right is we've got almost
almost 18,000 of you with us thanks for
being here no matter where you're
watching on twitch on YouTube on chess
TV directly yeah
Peter daughers and the chess TV chat
saying that's a study like variation and
indeed indeed it probably as amazing
endgame okay well there's still another
work ending going on and that's between
the car Nakamura and Yan the palm Nishi
here and Hikaru you know I was spying
this game for a while robber there were
some more exciting finishes you young
you doing work against JKD Hari Krishna
but hey Karl used his time really
deliberately in this game unlike unlike
total Hikaru fashion I guess because we
see him stream so much in bullet right
but but I actually think it was really
smart Robert he really he really grind
it out a small advantage and he's put
himself I don't know if this has any any
any real winning chances but he's the
only one who can win and this is gonna
be tough for young
yeah these BB pawns are no fun to deal
with in the rook on b5 keeps that rook
stuck to the sixth rank if you're
looking at black's rook but one of the
issues here right now that rook moves
off the pawn so the rook from east six
is freed but it can't go anywhere
there's nowhere for that rook to take
advantage of rook back to c6 makes sense
you can go rook to c4 and how does he
card me progress that yeah that's that
that's the tough part because looking at
it undeniable an undeniable advantage
you have the H pawn but but progress is
another question
hikaru is uh thinking here leaning up in
his streamers position that's a rare
Hikaru position right there or his
facial expressions go King a5 he plays
what's the idea he's giving up the H
pawn is he gonna
is he gonna flip a mating that up in
this
then the king just run away so he's over
d7 I guess that's a bad name idea of ago
this was much about her you threatened
h7 and hit this
hmm that's actually a really clever yeah
and rips it Hey
well I guess you could play b5 but then
you always have to worry about the Chuck
and the pawns okay he does and look at
you on stage sounds like yeah that was a
good move that 101 hmm wait you can play
that cuz now f6 is hanging and I can't
come back to c6 anymore
and that was the hikaru naught of
confidence Accardo number five Mambo
number five
actually I don't even know what black
does here
rook before it takes up six and if you
take if you take the epon and we're just
gonna switch over here to the queenside
rookie fund allows the room for the king
it's so funny when you can trade into a
king and pong game when you're gonna be
down upon temporarily because our King
is so much closer wow this would be the
third loss in a row for yelling upon me
XI and this would be wait
you're correct okay I was waiting but I
didn't know where you're going with it
well I was doing the math again in my
head it's been it's been a long week
with a lot of chess so but Hikaru is
putting on a show here for board one of
Team USA this victory will guarantee a
tide match and puts a lot of pressure on
Wesley so to hold against Sergey
Karjakin where he seems to be a little
worse we'll come back over to that in a
second another game that's still rolling
on if you want to go over to chess calm
slash events or just go chess calm slash
ONC Games is firuze versus video
Gujarati so uh interesting game still
going well how is the core of winning
here let's give the people a line Robert
okay he's no kini six and go rook d5 and
go King DISA he's just going to bring
his king over towards the like looking
for we go here the rook waits and we did
we just rinse and repeat and then I'm
gonna go King d7 uh-huh and then go
route D six take your be pawns and your
king is way too far away to help you so
at the right time you can't just sit and
hold and hold hold the C file because we
check switch to a traditional rook
ending where this pawn is gonna fall and
an easy sort of loose mussina mussina
mussina what is the correct
pronunciation of that I don't know I'm
not I've always heard Lucena but that
probably means I heard incorrectly well
that's what I'm saying now and I don't
know why I just doubted that but I did
yeah fantastic endgame right now by
Hikaru we were wondering what the plan
was right here Robert and he showed us
it looked like black had set up a
blockade but Hikaru had a had a really
strong idea in mind King f5 was gonna
meet King takes h5 with this move and
instead King f5 was met by the brook
coming up but then Hikaru is is now
squeezing his way toward the Queen side
and that's a nice move rookie six yeah
because just going out for the pond
saying the black king is so far away
that by stealing your pawns my B pawn is
too strong as a remaining passer and I
will make sure that I get a queen so
phenomenal technique by Hikaru when I
only first tuned in here I was saying
that it looks like black should hold
maybe I just miss evaluating this
endgame completely and yeah your initial
take apply like a car was positioned
there and a great game by a car yeah and
as soon as he started givin the Hikaru
Bombo nod number five I knew that there
was some depth there he's uh spying into
his webcam by the way speaking of brook
headings that maybe didn't go the way we
expect it let's go over to wesley shows
game with Sergey Karjakin because he was
he was worse as white a little bit ago
is he
is he's still worse anymore I don't
think so how did this happen I mean a
few moments ago then the position I was
spying was was something like this with
the imbalance of the night versus Bishop
Akari Aachen trades the the minor pieces
off the board and then in a panic to
defend the G pawn has to give a
protection of the C file and Wesley is
in in a very good shape this draw would
potentially win the match for Team USA
if the car Nakamura converts against
yonder pawn machine I mean I'm looking
at this position physical only white can
win now I which is a shocking turn of
events considering how good cardiac ins
position was earlier and for Team USA
this would be a tremendous victory India
got their first win of the tournament
team win that is and China beating
Europe allows the USA to join them with
a match victory for the American squad
Wow
well Team USA has never needed a win
more because of China's slowing down
Europe again Vichy and on did be tamer
of her job off we already showed you the
Hari Krishna very nice finishing against
Jorge Cory so there'll be a lot of
chests to look at during the break as we
prepare for round 8 so if you're just
tuning in one of the twenty
thousand-plus
don't go anywhere the party is just
getting started here on day four or five
depending on how you want to look at it
of the online nations cup
so this game here the both player is
still thinking I mean
Ruchi for played by car yeah Qian with
not that much time remaining by the way
and for Wesley can you just go rook
takes e5 and hey Ken's rate rate I think
you can't he's taking his time here
Wesley calmly calmly pointing out he's
in control here of the clock
[Music]
we're learning quickly I'm just gonna
flash that position as this was likely
gonna be a draw Hikaru looks moments
away from converting that bee pollen and
beating Yan upon me she so as long as so
draws this Team USA is in great shape
there are no other teams going in this
round all the rest of Arusha beat vidi
gujrati but it didn't stop Team India
from getting their first victory yes
Danny what I was going to say was that
if I were Wesley I mean we just flashed
the position of the car it's completely
winning but I was just it's over sorry
go ahead
I would have waited until the moment it
was completely winning before I made my
move if I had that kind of time
remaining because look at Wesley's
position he should never lose a game
like this and I'm just you know putting
the pressure on the Russian players and
now that had car Nakamura wins you can
make it draw at any moment just you
don't want a blunder here yep
hikaru the the rock for Team USA I
complimented him as the rock yesterday
and he he played it down but the truth
is it's just it's been true he's the
only tape person for Team USA who's
played every single game and hasn't lost
and now has beat you and upon me she
twice in this event although to be fair
the players not playing around is not
really their fault it's a team captain's
decision so 5-under Caruana Sano game
day two I don't really think Fabiano
didn't want to play that day well and in
hindsight I guess Team USA missed him
that day right obviously it was not the
best day for lay near lay near dominguez
but there's a carro hanging out in chat
yep you're doing Johnson now buddy
the rock is holding it down but okay at
this point all Wesley needs to do is
hold this one down for Team USA this is
the most important game currently as
long as he gets this draw
so if he just takes on before here I
think that we just see them agree
in the next few moves we definitely will
have some games to look at at the break
again we got to break down how all the
eraser faroush ax beat bit of gujarati
give you some final looks into the crazy
games that were you young versus young
christoph Duda Hari Krishna's very nice
win so we've got lots of chess to look
at assuming that this game ends soon I
guess um maybe maybe that's maybe that's
it right there Robert he's just gonna
say you know what you got you got
nothing Sergei
well no Wesley wants more no Wesley I
don't think Wesley wants more he just
says making moves and he'll go back
James X No
hey see my king can just sit behind your
pawn and if you ever push to g5 my king
goes to g6 and you put your pawn to g4
my king goes to g5 so the king will
follow the pawns progress is what must
his claim yeah that's a kind of an
instructive point just to show if this
pawn advances and the King follows it
eventually you can't actually win with
this in fact you could only get yourself
in trouble and maybe lose that pawn
eventually okay the trade has happened
rook takes 80 will be met by key no
Wesley wants more he's not taking the
drug which is just I mean it's good
right that's funny but you could have
easily traded g6 but now we get a draw
the old fashioned way King versus King
the way it was meant to be and I love
that they're playing it out this is
great don't think upon yet oh give us
wipe your memory completely over the top
melodramatic movie about the medieval
times it comes down to King versus King
mono e mono but lots of those ending
piece here on the chessboard anyway
alright the round seven of the online
Nations Cup saw some similar stuff team
China dominating but Team Europe has
finally been slowed down meaning Team
USA has joined them likely it's now
officially a two horse race to see who
will join China in the Super Final on
Sunday Russia not out of it yet but
looking tough Robert so we got lots to
come to to get to when we come back
we're gonna take a very short break join
us for round eight previews and a
highlight breakdown of Round seven when
we return
[Music]
you
hi dad hi dad I'd hate that okay dad you
know rough times we're doing our best
here but you know I just want to sit on
your lap and just tell you just cry
about things right now you know ya know
it's great to have you Wesley so Grand
Master Wesley so for those who don't
know he's playing for Team USA and also
recently competed in an event for
charity adopted Danny adoption is when
you win ten games in a row for those who
don't speak chess lingo and hence the
respect I now show my father when he's
on screen but Wesley given his respect
to us right now he wants to take us
through this game starting with the move
rook e8 so tell us about this move by
Sergei and what your thoughts were yeah
well actually I prepared the again
Sergei
yesterday because he plays the bird
Berlin and I figured I had some time so
I spent like an hour preparing why not
but then in the game he played he
delayed castling King side usually
castles early but he played f6 first
right so he doesn't he does he doesn't
want me to attack on the Kings side with
g4 h for whatever three plays at six
first and waiting for me to custard
before a castle but I also played this
position with black so Castle CT okay
eight and they played this in a
game against an opponent in India a few
months ago but I don't recall exactly
what Ian played I thought he played
before but up I fight in the game I
played before that was the normal time
but it's actually a bad move so I said
before I should have played before and
Queen B 3 and apparently this is the
theory I checked after the game ok what
is the essential point that opening up
the Center helps Black was the two
bishops and maybe the rook is well
Pleasant e8 hitting your eforp on yeah
exactly because e 4 and B 4 hanging back
of the bishop pair and his King side is
very safe so here actually after rook e1
Knight b6 black us absolutely no
problems and he can easily seize the
initiative
because of this bishop pair so I thought
I was still following some games with
this like I remember BC Annan has a game
against a nice theory but it's probably
not this exact same position but was it
let me ask you a question really quickly
when you think you're following some
other theory but you're maybe mixing up
a move or two or it's a slightly
different position how dangerous is that
for you when you're playing these super
strong grandmasters like yourself well
it's very dangerous actually because if
you think at first they're fighting for
an advantage you think is realizing
better but actually you're slightly
worse well what here what happens to
your mindset they're right specially in
a team event we're not to say you
wouldn't recognize oh I've messed up
theory and maybe need to get a draw in
an individual again but an event but in
a team event do you instantly kind of
switch your mindset - hey I know I was
supposed to be the one with white and
pushing for the team but I just got to
make sure I don't lose to Corey Aachen
here
okay I don't think about the results
during the game because I think it's
detrimental I just try to play the
position but yeah what's disappointed
because I usually in a team event is the
white pieces that that push in the black
pieces at home but here I got absolutely
nothing with with white and in fact
during the game I was happy to people's
public win did there also was another
mistake because the Queen looks a bit
fragile on bt like he could play c5 and
exploit the pin right but but I was
ready to repeat moves into opening
because I figured that I should play
objectively and and not push too hard
even with the white pieces because he
could you could you could lose I mean if
you had better position you're playing
but if you have the worst position like
that in your base the offering a draw
here with my c4 but of course he does
not take it with Bishop e6 and instead
played c5 yeah I didn't realize how
about my position is here actually I
thought you would do big moves but after
c5 drug is not risking anything because
of his Bishop there so then I'm gonna
I'm gonna make some moves quickly and
kind of jump ahead and so when did you
feel that it started to maybe turn
around you you obviously did hold this
game and we're doing just fine by the
end but
at what point do you feel maybe Sergey
missed a chance or or something that
something different could have happened
well I don't think he missed a big
chance I thought that was quite safe
here in the endgame
I mean black is possibly only it's
probably close to equal at this point
but maybe I made some mistakes and he
got the slightly better position again
but after the Queen's were exchanged I
felt pretty much safe I figured I had
enough counterplay to to equalize Wesley
while you are considering yourself
somewhat safe were you also just
nervously looking at your teammates
games to make sure that maybe you didn't
need to play for a win like how are you
balancing your own game with say a
Cara's game which ended up winning yeah
well I I obviously glanced at my
teammates games here and then when when
my opponent is thinking and actually at
some point I think Sergei got
disconnected for for half a minute or so
we missed that yeah I think he got
disconnected
for half a minute later on but earlier
before this petition but yeah I mean I
obviously glanced here and there to
check how my teammates are doing but
it's not really a big deal because my
position was was not better right at any
point so it's not like I have a choice
whether to be losing or winning and it
doesn't change what you have to do right
the day your game is still the most
important but I'm very pleased that he
threw one he's him in Fabiano really
carrying out the team and also Irena
defended this ending of Brno I thought I
thought she had a difficult slightly
difficult endgame once but she ended
very well I'm just kind of playing
through it to let those who maybe just
tuned in what know exactly what happened
but as you said nothing to it and
eventually it was a draw so
congratulations on the hold that
ultimately won one that head-to-head
matchup with Russia so as you look at
you look at the standings you're now
tied with Europe or one do you know if
you'll be playing in
date are we allowed to say that yet and
and to how do you feel about your team's
chances here in the in the final three
rounds before the super final yeah I
think they release the bearings the
lineup already so I'm playing or the
next game not sure your thumb playing
but a bit black but well obviously China
will take first place what
they're very good team how fun is should
be playing on the men's on the men's
board to be thanked there are simply no
answers to her but yeah I mean Levon
Aronian is basically I think carrying
the team Europe he played very well
yesterday also the day before that I'm
not sure what happened to his aim he
drew today versus what he yeah yes so it
all think it all depends on how the one
is doing if one isn't fired and it's
very hard to beat Team Europe but but if
he starts miss playing then yeah and
also they have a very good women player
with none a dog needs a she's she's very
aggressive well fingers crossed we will
try our best but things are still far
from clear it's very competitive right
now with thank you for Shirin well
Wesley we appreciate your time so much
we will let you go if you're playing you
should probably get in your game shape
but thank you so much for spending time
with us sure good luck here at the next
round
okay bye son bye dad make sure to thank
your oh man I couldn't ask for her for a
kinder father I gotta be honest the game
there between Wesley so and Sergey Karl
can you see the final position on the
board came down to the Kings and Wesley
held held a big one so Wesley's awesome
it's so much fun and it starts me
thinking about but the next time I have
to defend my honor and try not to become
and expand the family a nice giri will
be attempting to win ten in a row
against me coming up at some point over
the next month or so so
looking for the next adopted Annie where
we also always raise money for the Dave
Thomas foundation for adoption that'll
be coming up but alright time for us to
talk about what's coming up next as we
get set for round eight we're gonna look
at some of these other final positions
of the games of round seven but before
we do we have the pairings of round
eight and so uh let's run through them
let's do it because we have team Europe
trying to rebound against Team India
India put forward a impressive
performance this morning winning their a
first match of the event all right Patel
Hari Krishna
he's been excellent form despite his
inability to beat John Christophe Duda
and a MouseMan when you're making those
comments like he has some bad results
because of things that just were out of
his control while they were in his
control but you know what I mean but
anyway yeah when we look at this matchup
Levon Aronian as Wesley so said in great
playing shape he takes on video Gujarati
who struggled mightily again he said
when you look at this matchup here I
think it's all Team Europe but what
about you
it's hard to pick against them again as
you said vid it is just he's not not he
hasn't played his best chess in this
event and we love him to death you and I
both and he joins us for commentary but
you know it hasn't been his best best
event I don't know that they have a
better option anyway I mean he's still a
fantastic player and and can find it at
any time but when you think about him
going up against Levon Aronian that's a
tough one maybe it'll be what he needs
to kind of rise to the challenge I'm
looking forward to the rematch of Hari
Krishna y'all kristef do know though if
I'm honest cuz still don't know how Hari
didn't win that game against JKD but but
that'll be an interesting rematch now
that Yong Kristoff gets the white pieces
so Team Russia and Team China this is a
big one obviously for Team China to just
continue to make sure that nobody can
tie them at this point they're the only
team that hasn't lost a match of course
and that's why they're leading the event
as as Wesley so said it's unfair that
Hoey fawn is on board for in a lot of
ways and I think I said the same thing a
couple days ago I don't really disagree
with them but Danny I have to ask you a
question here because if you were the
team captain of China would you ever sit
you Yangyi based on how well he's
playing
uh you know what that's a fantastic
point and and the answer's no I wouldn't
I wouldn't have sat him and and so yeah
that's I I wasn't even thinking about it
cuz I was looking at how Yvonne stepping
in is the biggest story line over there
instead of you and June but yeah Wow
well if team China does suffer their
first loss that's definitely gonna be
what we're talking about right Sergei
car yeah and I don't know that you can
ever be happy to go against Wang Hao or
Wei Yi but he's got to be happy not to
be playing you yongi and I will say that
perhaps it's you know right before the
playoff time you see this in basketball
getting some rest some low drainage Minh
before the playoffs because sunday is a
super final China is assured that they
will make it there pretty much at this
point so maybe yang you just said I'll
take this one off I've done enough
putting the team on my back this far
well speaking of putting the team on
your back kick our Nakamura has been
leading Team USA on board one and
hopefully hopefully for Team USA they'll
continue to do so an interesting shake
up there as instead of team over job off
on board 1 we now have Olly Reza
firoozeh stepping oh now you're talking
Danny that's a doctor for Asian people
wanted Oh taking on a car Nakamura
onboard one I mean the people have
spoken
yeah chess captains have answered their
calls and so team or a job he has been
struggling as of late he lost I came to
vision often Anand and so you know it's
time for Ali Raisa it's time for him to
shine but Hikaru Nakamura has been as
you called him a rock throughout this
entire event he hasn't lost a single
game he's survived bad positions he's
pressed in 1 positions that you know you
didn't think he was going to win and
Jana Palma she he swept in this
tournament but Alireza version with the
white pieces Hikaru Nakamura with black
Danny what do you make of this matchup
which also includes ba sama means
scooting up to bore to forehead Cory on
three and of course Maryam Uzi Chuck
taking on you're in a crush on the
fourth board well I have to be honest I
still I still favor Team USA based on
the fact that Caruana on board to is
okay not performing as mightily as Levon
Aronian but after that I mean if Bobby
has been fantastic and
a huge part of their early match
victories so he gets boss Emma mean I
think Bobby's definitely the favorite
there and Wesley so I think is the
favorite against Jorge Cory so I think
the hype rightfully so for the online
chess community Robert circling that
firoozeh Nakamura matchup maybe maybe
Timur was like hey you know what I just
want to watch for Usha play a card with
some popcorn so I'm gonna sit out and
grab that scotch I've been sipping and
watch Perugia and Hikaru I don't know I
mean maybe it was Taylor's idea but we
got to focus on that but I don't know I
still think Team USA is is is the
favorite for sure and that and that
upcoming battle so alright we want to go
through some of these other games here
that that finished in round 7 that you
and I didn't get to see the final
moments - starting with Vichy and Dawn's
victory over team over job off maybe
another reason he needed a break this
final position is resigned because after
the move rook to d7 there's no way for
black to deal with the coming threats of
both c7 c8 as well as just moving the
night and and and winning some materials
so your thoughts on any of the other
critical moments from this game between
Vichy and verge above I just think we
were saying earlier after the opening
when black gave up a pawn or the a pawn
was lost
and it was one of those situations where
you're on shaky territory if your team
or a Java because you're sort of all in
at that point if you ever attack amounts
to something then you have compensation
but if white is able to fend it off then
you are down a pawn and I mean your
played Vishy Anand so yeah he doesn't
really need much more than a slight
initiative or an edge to take that into
a full point yeah again everybody Robert
was referring to this position right
here right after white had won the pawn
with the trade and then this was really
the last moment that we actually got to
look at the game live there was so much
other action but vichy defended defended
and then consolidated right with the
extra pawn so like you said it was uh it
was an all in a fair for Taymor we did
come back quickly to this moment
he played Knight takes c3 as you
suggested and he knew you couldn't even
take f2 because of rook b7 would just be
just be too much to deal with so yeah
just it seemed like a very very clean
game for bishi honestly
they forward and yeah the 97 movie that
gets a protective potency six always a
blow if you're trying to defend a
position you know at least I'll get that
advanced pawn but once 97 comes you can
play Bishop f6 because of 95 and yeah
just your whole position collapses yeah
tough one there okay so
Tamwar goes down vichy gets a win for
Team India they get their first match
victory if you if you missed the memo
but that all came despite a bit of
gujaratis loss to a larezo firoozeh the
final position is resigned here because
excuse me moving they came forward would
allow d7 and welcome done'
to d8 baby girl and if the King backs up
there's just too much pressure here
again the bishop and once again d7 is
gonna be too much so I'll play through
this one and just let you give your
thoughts again obviously on vidit
struggles wishing and wishing that he
could turn it around but I guess he's
got to be happy that his team won right
right the team success comes first but
we'd be lying if we didn't say that when
we have a bad result individually it
doesn't really affect us and he looked
like he played an interesting game here
look at Queen on 82 yeah from the black
side of things yeah I'm going it
definitely was not a I know I'm not in
great form I'm gonna play scared game I
mean this is a super-sharp opening but
maybe the Queen on a2 was regrettable
soon rook takes f6 and the opposite code
Bishop attack I guess if we were
covering this one in more detailed live
we would have been highlighting the fact
that whenever you have ops the code
bishops and one side has King side
pressure and the other does not it can
be it can get very dangerous because as
soon as as soon as pressure starts
coming to the dark scores that Bishop is
a bystander he gets the Queen's off the
board but it doesn't change that the
dark squares are a serious problem and
blacks mean you know point of success is
this a pawn if you can eventually push
it on the board but as we saw on the
game it looks like the pawn got
somewhere but not far enough yeah
playing through it it was again it was
it was dynamically equal here almost I
mean black is worse but he held his own
where was the critical moment as we get
to again g7 under pressure d6 under
pressure and I guess that's where the
material starts to go down steel
obstacle Bishop's you think Black has a
chance
I actually I'm surprised to see that
this game resulted in the loss yeah now
that I'm looking at it me too although
the more this endgame goes on I guess
the two pawns are gonna be too much so
maybe his name is rating the rooks was
actually less than ideal perhaps keeping
the rooks on the board I mean what are
your thoughts on this you're the you're
the Grandmaster what do you evaluate
here when you're trying to hold an
endgame like this I think in some ways
you think about getting the rooks off
the board when you feel very confident
in a blockade because the rook is better
at helping white get a second weakness
right that would be the the mindset I
would have so I would trade rooks if I
think I can blockade easily with the
bishops so maybe that's the mistake is
he can't actually blockade these two
pawns and maybe miss evaluated that I
mean he could definitely blockade them
and he should have blockaded them I
don't know where it went wrong but rook
d7 has to be a fine move and even taken
d6 there instead of taking on c5 as
possible okay so then we're yeah
actually this actually looks like it
would have been an easier blockade
because there are no to pass pawns
my main reference I guess was that once
the once the two passed pawns occurred
it was gonna be much harder to blockade
so you still think it should've been a
draw here yes really
yep yes where do you think I mean keep
going
and that's the really annoying thing is
that obviously whites blacks kingside
pawns aren't don't square so you're
gonna need to defend those at some point
so keep going so he tries to defend them
by trading them right right right and
then gets them on a light square that's
good
again I mean this ain't game this is
this has already lost four black like
yes I don't understand where where you
think black could have blockaded this
differently the two passed pawns
immediately here are pretty tough I mean
so hmm to me I mean blacks best chances
to draw already keep the pieces on the
board and if I would if I was playing
black I would have loved to have been in
a position where my Brooke could have
been behind this pawn I don't know if
that's like a bishop situ with a five
and coming around but maybe I maybe just
rook takes d6 instead of B takes d5 was
the critical moment yes yeah and that
that that makes it a lot harder to
imagine because in this case if white
ever plays d4 you can sit on the light
squares right you you guard you guard d7
you can't move the bishop immediately
because because then d7 is a problem so
you guard d7
but then then the king comes up so I
guess it was a little tricky but this
should still be much much better for
black as far as drawing chances go than
what he got in the game yeah yeah I mean
my chess instincts are telling me this
should have been a draw and did it knows
it now the razor knows it but then you
give those past pawns as you were saying
and once they start mobilizing every
single turn you're worried about them
becoming Queens because of how easily
they can push forward so I would have to
analyze this further than to know if
there was a better blockade but this
already feels like was just a bad
decision to give the to pass pawns so
easily and take the rooks off the board
so all right well vintage struggles but
as you said the team victory is what
matters the other highlights are the
round for those who might have missed it
one of the the biggest moments that I
already saw some fans were sharing on
Twitter at the break was your you know
what's not a mouse lip you know what's
not a mouse lip Robert has wasn't that
your nickname and not in high school in
college yeah you actually you know at
some point texted me and told me that
you saved my name in your phone book is
that but night 65 really a classy move
there's every single black piece tied
down and Brooke on a fade that's the
real problem is it's not defended only
one time and no matter how you capture
that Queen is not going to be able to
protect it yeah this was amazing Knight
takes e5 if you missed it check out the
clip someone made it crazy move again if
you take with the F pawn rook takes a
fate if you take with the Queen Queen
takes f8 and if you take with the pawn
you take d7 and then take FA so FA it's
a problem and as well as things like
Knight takes g6 ohori Corey just
resigned this was a huge win but tella
Hari Krishna I mean I know India can't
win the event Robert but that's got to
feel good right for him to start riding
the ship he lost cuz of a mouse slip
yesterday so that's that's a win that
Team India as a country feels good about
yeah whenever you can just at least
score a team match victory you have to
be happy and you're no longer in the
cellar and the cellar dweller who
remains the team that's comprised of
flairs from the rest of the world but
for Team India they can actually finish
this one ahead of Team Russia right
they're a very strong team they're about
to you know compete in round not for an
eighth losing track of what round we're
on because you're two rounds everyday
it's an even round run eight coming up
even in this run they can leapfrog rush
on the standings and that will just feel
better
considering where they were to start the
day lastly let's show the other
highlight of the round was again from
the board three of China this was a this
was a great game a line in the nihms oh
that I have struggled with too often as
black I'm just gonna just gonna say that
but the chest Panda one two three as
he's known on chest calm you young he
gets it done young Christopher do to get
some big trouble and the attack just
well he never look back
right hashtag rhyme time here goes Queen
g4 we came to the board here and we're
like uh-oh rook takes me for turns out
maybe not the most accurate I guess but
it didn't really matter
he played Knight G to e4 and then the
mate was on here Bishop h6 blows things
open with East six and Robert found the
finishing tactic took me a little too
long to see it this move Bishop to g7
because after King takes 96 and heading
to the h-file is made for white so you
young ye again he's your MVP right
undoubtedly I mean if I were in charge
of giving these awards young he for sure
is the most honorable player for in this
entire event so then the question is as
we bring up around eight the full
pairings in front of your face right now
right why is it you yang Yi in the
lineup
what are you doing China like you said
giving him some rest I guess load
management yeah DNP load management is
what's happening with you yang Yi and
also it's good because you want to
figure out who your lineup should be
Dingley right is going to play and then
wang hao is excellent and he's you know
one of the players in the Canada's
tournament but so is way he and used
provide a spark for China at times too
so I think that you're just trying to
determine who oh you're a third board be
between Dingley Ren you yummy you know
that they're going to spearhead the
lineup and then between Wang Hao and way
you who's in better form yeah I see a
common in chat there USA has the big
guns out they've had that lineup out now
for a few rounds and not to take
anything away from from the other
players but this seems to be the team
that USA is gonna have to kind of ride
to the end here and then you've got Team
Europe right they're going with the same
lineup they just fielded so that'll be
that'll be interesting to see how that
one goes down they lost to China of
course but then again who hasn't so
should be super exciting that's coming
up here and not less than about 10
minutes so don't go anywhere round 8 is
on the way let's remind everybody of the
full schedule
just so you know we will be here yet
again tomorrow on Saturday May 9th where
the final the final results will be in
we will know at the end of tomorrow who
is competing on the super final Sunday
Mother's Day it will be and anyway can't
wait for the weekend
everybody's working for the weekend I
mean you know I I'm looking for that we
can accept that on the weekend off do I
so I am looking forward to the finale of
this event and then getting to the Super
Final because team China they've been
just absolutely fantastic from start to
finish we're not there yet but they're
not dropping any points they have not
blown any key games and so you just have
to credit them for being stable and for
being strong and nobody has been able to
put a dent in their all-star lineup oh
yeah it's been crazy and again our first
daily question in the beginning of this
event was indeed who do you think is the
favored to win a lot of people said
China a lot of people were right so very
often not very often that happens on
social media but there you go
all right well Robin are gonna take a
very quick break when we come back the
final preview then round 8 begins more
from the feed a chess comm online
Nations Cup when we return
[Music]
a Premium Membership at chess comm we'll
help you improve your game with full
access to a powerful set of learning
tools unlimited tactics let you practice
like a master with more than 50000
puzzles to challenge you at every level
our library of interactive chess lessons
created by master coaches will enhance
every aspect of your game and after each
game you play the computer analysis
feature will give you feedback on every
move you play turning every game into a
chance to learn and that's not all
premium benefits also include unlimited
tournaments video lessons the opening
Explorer and much much more upgrade now
to take your game to the next level
and we are back here once again just a
couple minutes away from the start of
round 8 the feed HS calm online Nations
cub thank you to everybody that's with
us more than 20,000 of you on Twitch
2,500 on YouTube lots of other platforms
we appreciate your support it means a
lot just like the European online Chess
Championship it's the first ever online
event of its kind so kind of a big deal
the ECU throwing it down normally they
have their individual Championships
around this time of year so if you're
looking to sign up for an event not
something we we hold very often the
first ever kind of pay to play event
that we've really held since the world
fish a random Chess Championship last
year consider playing in it just like
Robert has considers playing in the
title Tuesday every week Robert you're
gonna play next Tuesday I'm gonna try I
love time Tuesday it's fun to put the
best blitz players in the world you see
the players on the image there in
addition to others like Alexander grill
show candy scary and you know if you're
lucky you're gonna play me because it
means you probably win oh man that's not
true at all except you do play from your
phone a lot so it makes it makes the
time scrambles tough although I'm
regularly impressed with your ability to
blitz on the mobile app if I told you
that lately this first time you've
complimented me all day thank you that's
not true at all you're just you're just
you know you're not hearing the
positivity right now but speaking of
mobile apps that you play on you blitz a
lot on them we also have a mobile app
that everyone should consider
downloading and trying the doctor wolf
app is almost available on Android maybe
it is as it this week I actually
apologize for that I lost track of the
product workflow for my team focused on
this event but the doctor wolf app truly
is amazing it's it's a fantastic
fantastic way to learn from your own
game so consider giving it a try
especially if you're already an iOS user
if not it'll be on Android if not
already so Robert s and I are here
moments away from the next round the
feed a chess comm online Nations Cup
it's it's been a lot of fun we've got so
many of the best players in the world
six of the top chess nations and I don't
know why I feel I have to put that in
quotations but I do because some of them
are not nation exact you get it Robert
but $180,000 in prizes and the first
ever event of its kind leads us to the
current standings we have
team China we have to start talking
about something else cuz there is so
good it's like they're just good I don't
know what else to say besides that
they're playing well the team is amazing
they have beef on now she's taking on
board for for this round but when she's
not playing
she went Jew and that's I even like a
substitute that just you're choosing
between two of the two best options in
the world at this point so I'm you know
of course other teams are trying to stay
in it with China but from top to bottom
China just continues to dominate
remember everybody because the event is
structured in a way to give us a super
final meaning on Sunday there will be
another match of the top two teams so
playing for second place is I know that
sounds weird but this isn't a Ricky
Bobby movie right it the same if your
first your last that's not the truth if
your second you're actually moving on
with a chance to get first so as we look
at the full round a pairings here it'll
be interesting to see who can stay pace
in second place it seems like a two
horse race
Russia not mathematically eliminated but
Team Europe and Team USA they have a lot
on the line now they do because now that
the USA is tied with Europe for second
place one of those two teams will
advance to face China in the Super Final
and I just wanna remind everybody may
ask what is the advantage of being the
top seed here you actually get draw ads
in the Super Final so team China they
are rewarded for their let's call it
regular-season performance and then they
will have draws in the super file that's
it almost seems unfair to give them draw
odds give another fling right maybe they
should give some what piece odds Oh God
alright just getting yan depandi she
playing ding me right now and the board
one matchup between Russia and China
respectively
another board one matchup MBL is taken
on mission one Athan Anand
we've got hit car Nakamura taking on all
the rest of Perugia another board one
battle we are spoiled this round Robert
this is gonna be a lot of fun and the
board two battles aren't any less
exciting neither are the other so I'm
looking at all the games getting going
if you see an opening you like just just
yell my name say my name I'm letting you
lead the way for now I know it's
dangerous then don't do it very often
but I'm trusting you this time you're
you're saying Danny take the wheel and I
shall do so I like where we're at here
in terms of Olly Reza firoozeh and the
car Nakamura but the same oh I was gonna
say the same opening about to occur
maybe that we've seen so many times hey
Karl played this as white against magnus
carlsen at the magnus invitational but
we've also seen it several times in this
event so this will be interesting but
not the same at first I thought maybe it
could almost be a similar kind of
structure anyway Bishop c5 was played
instead of Bishop before but a Queens
gambit declined over on the game between
MBL and and bishi and on so let's let's
talk a little bit about the Hikaru
perugia game it and compare this to all
the other games we've seen recently in
this exact same structure well I know no
visual compare just yet because they'll
show us that it's the same line and
we've seen some games where White was
able to punch their b5 we saw John
DePalma she beats team or a job of when
eventually b5 was played by Yann but
this is a different line because the
Queen's on c7 so as you're pointing out
you have four pawn is under attack
you should play g3 to defend that pawn
and with the Queen on c7 and sometimes
black plays Bishop a6 of course but
sometimes block with Bishop b7 rook a 7
bring the other rook to e8 and plays it
slower over there on the Queen side it's
interesting if Bishop e7 and this
doubling rook plant occurs that'll
definitely be something we haven't seen
quite yet or at least not very recently
no it doesn't occur Nakara goes for the
variation where we're definitely seeing
a little more often with the bishop
creating itself off so you've you've
highlighted really well Robert the the
things going on in this structure right
I mean there's I think we'll see the
trade but there's the the week's e6 pawn
that is a long term target sometimes
it's enough often it isn't in a close
very long game we also saw yawn upon me
she go for the the aggressive b5
approach and blow things open which
trades off the weakness but in turn
gains an initiative and yawn actually
went on to win his game versus tamer of
her job off in that line
so those are events sorry those are
games that occurred in this event
everyone so Bishop a6 has played and I
guess we'll see how ferocious wants to
uh wants to approach it and I'm curious
when Ali raises decision-making because
nothing he did anything wrong this far
he's still playing down a line we've
seen many times but all the race that
tends to be a more tactical aggressive
player by nature and so entering
territory that he knows he carro plays
extensively from both colors here I feel
like that's advantage Chikara yeah I I
can't disagree right Accardo seems
relaxed and obviously he knows these
positions really well I mean he's
playing them with both sides and with
success so this will be interesting to
see some shoutouts from chat wanting us
to look at Irina crush his game with on
a mu Z Chuck
so I'm sorry Maria mu Z Chuck so I'm
gonna I'm gonna do that we're gonna
entertain that idea and head over there
it's it's kind of tricky let's see
what's going on Irina doing very well
right now as the board for for Team USA
and this this would be another huge game
if she could she could convert on maybe
it looks like she could get a little bit
of an advantage here his white
well b5 is a tricky move because if you
take the Paul and thinking it's for free
then there's Knight takes d4 and that's
kind of the point here is that if you
take here take with check and then you
wind it back exactly I positively you
figure it out because I could sense you
like this has to be right but I need to
just double check real quick well I was
waiting for double checking any dragon
tactics sometimes you can take back and
it's enough but obviously taking e2 is
the right idea there so b5 is like a
Sicilian kind of tactic like I said it's
a dragon accelerator dragon kind of
tactic you can throw that move in like a
renegade pawn because of ideas like this
that occur normally in a dragon once
again this is a grünfeld but similar
kind of stuff in terms of the dark
square Bishop hitting the center
[Music]
okay well Irene it doesn't work line I
want to show Danny is it Bishop b5
Knight takes d4 Knight takes d4 then
black hats like Bishop takes d4 and the
point is that you know there have been a
bunch of hanging pieces but you have to
take me back on d4 now I take on b5
we're just trading a lot here and this
should be level opposite colored bishops
will be the endgame and probably a draw
will be the game depending on how USA
looks at their chances on the other
boards it's maybe not the worst idea for
Irina to try to write I guess you know
play play play for a position that's
simple but something told me she's not
going to go for that so
what's the other moves here if you're
not gonna take you just back up the
Bishop to b3 or did you go to d5 you can
choose either way and that's the nice
thing about whites position is that
there are some loose squares for black
because you've kind of overextended on
your queen side you get a head start and
if you look towards the end game where
you see one pawn for white on the a file
and two pawns for black and a and a 75
so it's a little bit of a head start but
it creates a weak is in c5 friends yes
maybe my rook will go to c5 double in
the C file or if I can reroute my knight
eventually a knight in to c5 looks good
so these are the double edged moves that
you can't take back and it just kind of
evidences the nature of how the scheme
will develop yeah I'm excited to see
what happens here the Grunfeld structure
versus the big center we will come back
to it so shout out to the chat for
drawing our attention there so many
other games as we've said I want to go
right back to the Sakura Purusha game
because it's moving along so quickly in
a variation that you said hey karo kind
of knows better than a lot of other
people but firoozeh Arusha all in here
with this F pawn advance which is kind
of cool right taking advantage of this
pin d6 pawn to the bishop on e7 but a
karo no pausing he takes on c5 and
remember how I said Yan wanted to reach
28 minutes with the increment Hikaru hey
Carter was trying to follow suit waiting
but this is bad for black we're just F
take C 6 here
I mean I'm actually very confused and
I'm worried about your car's position
yeah if Cardo leans in and thinks uh
wait a second because the point is if
you take on d4 b for let's say to come
b4 and then I take on d7 you take on c3
but your twenty sevens hanging at
the end yeah so what's going on
carpet looks very confused and he's
upset oh look at that face that was just
I'm disgusted with my play I moved too
quickly and I mean allowing f5 tends not
to be particularly good for black so
what went wrong here yeah he must have
been confusing his lines or something
right that's what happens when you
almost see a blunder at the opening like
this because especially given that the
clock management right if you have more
than 27 minutes you've been moving
faster than your ten-second increment
and you would probably only be doing
that if you're confusing your lines so
instead of instead of taking c5 I guess
blacks position would have still been
okay if he handled something something
different maybe maybe he could have
played a 5 yep
maybe if I definitely looks better than
then what's happening because after B
takes t5i I don't see a response at
least I'm an easy one to have take c6
he's gonna have to move the night just
be down upon but that just looks
terrible
I I'm in disbelief especially up to such
a nice game by a car earlier today and
maybe her car just need to play yonder
pawn machine every round because he's
beating him both times they played in
this tournament but Ali Raisa he played
half takes c6 right yep he has oh gosh
no no he has it he hasn't moved yet oh
that was just your announces okay yeah
yeah but what else is he thinking about
here is he him he's thinking by just
taking back on c5 of course but F takes
c6 that's a pawn
yeah I don't know Danny
so I don't know either man it looks just
clearly better for white and Purusha
taking his time because he also may be
slightly confused by he Cara's approach
here so interesting stuff there again
this is a matchup that a lot of people
have gotten used to seeing and these
guys go back and forth and bullet but
right now this is this is not gonna be
an advantage that Hikaru wanted to give
Purusha makes it makes me wonder what's
happening on the other boards here with
Team USA vs. team world I guess you
don't believe that
Hikari nothing more would make a mistake
though so that's maybe why all arrays
are sitting and thinking so long I'm
just trying to figure out what the
potential drawback of f66 is because
right when f5 so you can take on e6 and
it also loosens up the black king side
and yeah I don't know it looks just like
a mistake by a car and he knows it
have to come back and see how he handles
it I think faroush is gonna make the
move F take c6 and Hikaru was gonna be
in trouble
Bobby on a car won his game versus dr.
Basim Amin the good doctor looking
looking more important by that by the
second here for Fabiano try to get
something as white of a much much more
tame looking position than the paddle on
the board over there between firoozeh
and akaru yeah there have been
relatively few trades here just a couple
of ponds but there's Knight on c5 at
some point white will consider taking it
and then getting a passed pawn for
himself the deep pond will be and very
happy they're protected past no pawn in
the way but you also giving up your
bishop and when you look at these
positions you also think about instead
of capturing on c5 playing ideas like
you know Queen to d2 Bishop to h6 but
black is already sitting happily
attacking the pawn on e4 to start with
right which kind of forced the hand so
the Queen d2 Bishop h6 not really an
idea you want so he took instead and but
you've given up the bishop pair you give
black a couple moves they want things
like 98-96 to blockade on the dark
squares and and try to advance with f5
this move I like this move you're coming
to e3 maybe even to c4 you can obviously
play f3 at some point if you want to
hold the structure on f5 maybe g4 I
would consider Bishop h6 understanding
that you're trying to go 93 to d2 and my
bishops not doing all that much but one
of the big problems for black Dani is
that look at the pawn structure on the
Queen side
a5 b 7 c 5 there is a gaping hole on b5
and you would love you to push your pawn
to b5 at some point but with the knight
on c3 Bashan e2 and made even white
playing a4 at the right moment I'm just
closing in on these important squares on
the Queen side this is like the good
side of the Bodoni the Fabiano hasn't
been playing lately he needs to give it
up as black but we'll see yeah this is
like a good burn OD structure if white
gets all the things that Roberts talking
about here Knights on the light squares
and with this very very strong
positional advantage on d5 it's gonna be
tricky for tricky for pass em I mean by
the way amazing stuff over in the
ferrugiaro game
guess they're all arrested didn't take
he bought he bought the bluff almost
either that or there's some like super
deep idea there that even the computer
of what was going on he takes before
what would have been happening here
trying to figure that out right now I
really don't see anything
is it like some crazy idea that you take
and sack the peace I mean I don't think
so I'm just trying to throw things out
there like something like kind of weird
and unique no that just doesn't look
good there simplygon be four there can
you take F 66 C takes D four take on D
seven Bishop f6 or something like Bishop
f6 and then some kind of d3 is but that
also looks suspicious
interesting
baby I mean or maybe maybe your bishop
takes before move as well and just
stealing that pawn but well you have to
move the knight I guess and he said
we'll probably fall
but from all erasers perspective you
still must like this position you're up
a piece and you're forcing black to
prove he has enough compensation
it's like you imagine a fantasy world
where black gets to place c5 and get the
d7 pawn back and you're like okay well
there's a lot of pawns and the night
seemed kind of awkward but it makes me
wonder I mean what what these guys have
at home as far as is this literally ali
reza kind of buying the bluff cuz what's
shocking Robert is that he took six
minutes on the move and neglected to
take which is more time than effort than
you and I can put in right now right and
clearly they know the position in terms
of prep so either he just really over
thought this or there's something
something sneaky and deep about this
idea that he karo knows no I think you
just bought the bluff
yeah identity too it seems like the
simplest answer should be the right foot
look at how much time it car has how
quick please been playing and how much
experience he has solid races like I
mean f66 it looks good and I want to
trust myself but I in your car oh I
trust I've seen him play this so many
times I've researched his games but I
mean F take c6 feels like a missed
opportunity there apparently this is an
idea as well based on the fact that if
you take d7 maybe there's something like
you said what takes and d3 I don't know
I mean I'm with you it's very very
surprising but either way instead we we
see a capture back on c5 and then e 5
and now the position is totally unclear
so faroush it down on the clock and not
necessarily down on the board but
definitely no longer an advantage for
white it's becoming more double-edged
because white spawns do little
threatening over there on the kingside
of a 5 and f5 but black has the kind of
uncompromised pawn structure white has
double F Falls not that's that big of a
deal but the C and D pawns if they start
rolling then you can see blacks
compensation in full force oh I still
like white just on the basis that those
pawns there but you know timely rook e8
might also ruin my chances and get that
pawn on e5 yeah
crazy stuff
well if we if we end up getting an
interview or something we'll find out I
would love to figure out what the with a
deeper moment was there or what what
happened there but that was interesting
and thought we had to come back to
mention it so crazy stuff going on here
in this round eight lots of other games
going that haven't even gotten our
attention yet I'm spying the board and
if you see one go ahead and shout out
stuff I've been folks in this game so
you take us where we need to go let's go
over to Levon Aronian game
I mean Team Europe is also tied for
second and
with a lot to play for here
Aronian as black against video Gujarati
I guess I just spied the rook on d4 and
thought well that's interesting let's go
there is a future I admit a knight on d5
that looks good but I mean is black
going to be able to play move like b5
and just challenge the entire structure
because if black get some activity and
doesn't allow the whites of some in a
piece on d5 then I think that black
should out smoothly be okay okay prevent
it on the on the clock with a huge
advantage more than more than ten
minutes almost
Livan probably thinking about your idea
of b5 I guess makes sense you don't
typically see LaVon down so much time so
maybe he's been caught off guard by this
entire position I don't like the fact
that blacks King is on h8 it feels bad
particularly for end games and we've
already seen a bunch of trades if we see
more trades the King being over there in
the corner makes it further away from
the action
well this is gonna be a positional
battle of blackface b5 but I admit I
probably chose the wrong game for us to
go to because on second try against
buying so many great games I think we
have to go to this one between Jung
Christophe Duda infant Allah Hari
Krishna there's a king on f7 Robert and
whites down a piece this is gonna be fun
wow that is a fun one to see in yonkers
subdue to doing the reverse of what
Patel harkishen did to him because our
official just launched a huge attack
sacrificed in exchange and as we get to
the live position we'll see that well
dude is down it some material whether
the King enough 7 yeah sorry I was just
playing it you were mentioning the
previous battle they had were re Krishna
stacking exchanged and had a huge attack
in this game wait White's not down in
peace disease what we're going to see
you false alarm
oh my god I am not trusting you I said I
was gonna let you take the wheel I was
gonna let you steer the ship here and
then you tell me things like whites down
a piece so I was just talking and then I
look at the position like dang Mike's
not down a piece why she's totally
wedding by bad why I wouldn't go that
far
I don't think why it's totally white is
of course much much much better but you
know the longer this you know King
survives the age for pawn is now hanging
you consider taking it but of course
white is happy to have this position
wait it's a clear attack coming and not
in a very clear defense but I'm just
kicking over the fact that you told me
why was some piece and I feel lied to
I'm sorry I'm sorry I you know I made a
mistake
the the live position I I ran through
the opening and realized halfway through
wait a second he's not down a piece and
now now he takes h4 and so Hari Krishna
is defending actively not passively
jon-christopher really close up on that
cam now oh and he plays that five but
that's one of those moves that you know
it could it be too soon for that move
yeah because you're inviting pressure on
g3 although taking would allow the Queen
and enter with check so attempt these
saves the day and somehow I get the
feeling that white might sack apiece on
g3 for a quick castles long and bringing
pieces to the open files I'm trying to
figure out if I can take on g3 now and
how you take back maybe Queen uh yeah I
guess your point is if I take with the
Queen you take with tempo right right
and then I'm like Queen g5 and trying to
safeguard my king by active defense
right if I take with the bishop at the
very least you still can't take but that
feels weird right to retreat the bishop
I mean you just start looking at things
like check and stuff but but maybe
that's what I can do and play king d2
and here we go castle the O - then
there's Queen g5 with a check and that
doesn't look good night it for white so
write something like this and craziness
yeah black is
maybe there's ideas to give up g3 if you
get the attack going on at 5:00 so you
just want to justify the fact that you
said that white is down a piece by
sacrificing a piece later why not why
not it's not my pieces but in all
seriousness I mean you at first were
saying like the King on a7 you're right
I mean it looks so vulnerable but now
black is the one who's up a pawn you
know and if you don't have a direct your
checkmating attack and I fend you off
the longer this game goes black has a
lot of positives in this position you
know very solid pawn shocks from the
Queen side and I mean of course
checkmate ends the game but I don't see
that clear checkmate just yet yeah me
neither
and
and neither does uh neither does Hari I
guess that's why he was willing to take
that pawn because he didn't see a clear
way for his King to be destroyed he's
got a four-minute time advantage or you
know regardless of the result
Robert Hari has given us some of the
most exciting games in the event and the
biggest biggest drama moment might have
been his mouse slip unfortunately from
the previous day but still he's played
really aggressive fighting chess and you
know maybe that backfires in this game
but it's been fun to watch
it sure has and we have a results in the
books there's a draw between Sergei
Kuryakin and Wei Yi so that one is over
quickly showing it almost almost hardly
any fight their second game of the day
didn't deliver much fireworks so then we
come back here to Hari Krishna's game
this this will definitely be the
excitement of the round people yelling
for faroush and a card oh I get it I
hear you two of the biggest stars for
sure we're keeping an eye on it not as
exciting as this position though
remember you can head over to chefs comm
slash events or chess comms live server
go chess comm slash ONC games will also
deliver the glory and if you're on the
go it's easy as well so if you don't
like well recovering we encourage you
please go over there okay
I'm just looking at this Bishop III
Robert your move was played you're just
removing a potential attacker and I
think I'm just providing you from
castling so easily and Bishop takes g3
it was the response there and I do you
throw him to check on e7 this is a tough
question here because if you throw in
the check the bishop might come right
back to e5 so I would play Queen g5
first and say you're not castling
queenside and if you Castle kingside it
might be the white king that comes under
fire
yeah I'm excited about the idea that Y
can cast so long but you know what I
forgot is king could also still Castle
short but that mean Queen g5 castles
King side like who's king is going to be
worse I know it's so funny like Castle
kingside taking a five no longer on the
agenda and the other we're coming over
but again it's a weird position because
because black is primed to do just fine
over here on the Kings side as long as
you can deal with this issue yeah you
play Knight of six first and then now G
takes a five is a threat because my rook
and Queen are lined up against your
Bishop ones G three right and then
behind that the pawn on g2 would
checkmate so it's a real fight here in
both sides of chances and if you take
here the rook takes and big trouble
little G file during Kurt Russell the
okay well yeah this is this is gonna be
a wild one again there's so many great
games going on I'm I guess what will
give the fans of real quick shout out
will go back to Perugia karo just
quickly again if you if you missed it
this game may be already past its most
dramatic moment that had me in Robert a
bit shell-shocked to say the least
in this position it seemed that firoozeh
had something big working if he took he
six he elected not to who knows what's
going on for with that but now the
position looks just fine for black the
to passed pawns versus the two sort of
central pawns in the attack here right
and this is a Perugia now down on the
clock as well so gonna be a weird finish
and one thing black is to keep an eye on
is like an eventual f6 type of move or
and even in east six especially with
that rook on a seven because the black
king is a little bit lonely over there
so you can even sacrifice one of the
pawns to create threats and the other
free example e six if you capture me on
e6 I don't have any sort of checkmate
just yet but that rook on a7 and if you
can get the Queen attacking g7 as well
that could be a problem for black but
for now everything is under control
yeah the you'd love to to play Queen
before but maybe black even has e5 so
it's it's one of those things where you
start to smell blood in the water right
but you just don't see the the fresh
meat yet you've got you've got potential
here but but how do you how do you make
it work
if I know how to make it work I'd be one
of the players in this events that are
compensating on it
you can make nevermind I was gonna make
us go off on a different kind of
pop-culture tangent but I held back just
proving the people wrong that it is
possible for me to hold back all right
this game between Maxine Bushido Grove
and Vichy and on speaking of a different
board one battle other than Hikaru and
firoozeh nothing too exciting just want
to show it again Team Europe is a
favorite against Team India based on how
this event has gone but these the round
the round here is still anybody's around
rook d5 actually looks like a decent
move there from Anand and maybe we just
get equality something like King c-4
takes takes e5
where do you think this one is headed
maybe g4 I guess is the response instead
g4 Bishop takes d4 is perhaps possible
there just to say you take up c5 and
your Knights pinned and I get that back
but yep you know at first glance it does
look really nice for white promising
within an f5 because if you could play
g4 and King c4 at the same time white is
so happy in a position like this but of
course you don't get it make two moves
out once that's against the rules of
chess and if that's the case then blacks
fight just in time to hold the balance
my niece actually recently explained the
rules of castling to me and she said did
you know you can move two pieces at once
that's a good point
I misspoke but in this position you
can't well that's only one move now you
remember two pieces was only one way so
you can't make two moves at once yeah no
of course
kidding um so that's why I was wondering
if this is the right line because at
least you have the seventh rank threat
but blackton maybe just guard it and
maybe there's nothing to it I mean it
feels like Y should still be better like
you said the pawn structure feels like
the the active King does it count for
anything but but other than that because
of your bishop takes d4 line on g4 I
don't really see any other option yeah
yeah
that this one is going to be a hold for
Vichy he's been very sturdy throughout
this event
verse 30 and
out being a member he's the only team
captain and player for Team India so
they needed that they did get their
first win of the event last round if
you're just tuning in Team India finally
gets on the board with a match a match
victory again I'm just I'm spying this
game between Yonkers tip dude and how
are you Krishna I don't think we're
gonna get anything better this round I'm
having to go back there it's very late
we have another draw this round already
dawned upon me she and Dingley rent have
drawn so team rushes not not getting too
many fireworks on the board right now
versus team China understandably so I
guess but okay back to the Hari Krishna
game Knight f6 was played just as you
suggested and who has the attack here
castles was played this is a fun game
here I don't know who has the attack
because you know I as white I kind of
want to throw the f5 pawn off the board
like if you allowed me to make a move
here is why I just say f5 off the board
because you open up the app file for
your rook and that's actually a good
pawn to go down while not opening the
gfs look what he does
Yeji is going forward with my plan oh
please take me on a 5 with your queen
because then my F pawn is off the board
and the G file is not open and I'm just
going to move my Queen away play Bishop
e5 and you've problems down the moving
the Queen anywhere is gonna be super
tricky for black the next move things
like Bishop e5 doubling up on f6 so
that's interesting Bishop f4 hits the
Queen and of course y'all Kristoff
doesn't capture it he plays Queen dg4
instead well young Kristin's way so you
know I'm sorry catch Hari does not
capture a queen g4
so how do you give up that pot I'm
really fixating up on this idea but I
don't want to talk about g6 at five
yeah the only way to get rid of it is to
take but that helps black achieve
everything he needs oh I have an idea
what about Knight d1 because if you do
plate G takes a5 now I have Knight III
with a tempo on your queen protecting
the pawn on g2 and that suddenly allows
you to bring another attacking piece
into the game
idea Queen has to retreat and then you
can move your Bishop on the next the
next move as you talked about turning
that f-pawn disappearance into an
advantage
and the reason why is because you was 91
playing guess the move here Robert Hess
why I thought about this is I actually
had a lesson with a student recently and
we were talking about what looks like a
promising position but not being able to
convert it or to actually increase the
pressure and in a position like this
rook F to work a to f1 is one of the
ideas that for sure comes to mind but
you have to realize that your opponent
is also up to something and so I've
thinking my knight on c3 is not doing
anything the pawn to c6 just completely
stifles that piece and so as a pawn on
d5 as well and so let me bring my knight
to destroy III where in some ways it's
like a a bughouse to have a maneuver
you're attacking and defending
simultaneously and then you can press
forward when you fend it off your
opponent's threats of course it was
bughouse the knight would just be
dropping itself on d6 or h6 right now
with a fork but yes well well played I
love that 91-93 defend attack attack and
looking tricky again though I mean it's
it's a weird position all around still
seems like either player could could
have an advantage here I wonder at some
point if black hasn't moved that just
kind of laughs in the face of danger or
something okay seems crazy especially
because 93 is coming we got to deal with
that
but I'm wondering if there's a variation
Robert where somehow this king hides on
h8 and everything opening up ultimately
favors black yeah
King run at some point may be necessary
but I mean that 93 move looks so strong
and hard Christian could be considering
some kind of rookie aid in exchange sack
on e3 but White has to be happy about
what happens there so I know I wouldn't
go for this I don't think if I hurry but
no baby you're right I mean maybe it's
by the way how are you dealing with this
I mean this is coming and you already
pointed out how bad this is
so rookie 893 you take the exchange at
least there you can take on f5 I'm gonna
get my 94 next yeah actually this is
looking promising for black I think
maybe you were right maybe rookie eight
is uh is the best thing to do here Danny
this is where commentating comes in
really handy because since in when
you're playing you're thinking very
concretely in terms of right specific
moves when I on a competative I'm
thinking of general plans general advice
and to bring a piece into the game but
then thinking about how that's going to
affect black say we're gonna eights not
doing anything and I know I'm giving up
a rook for a less valuable piece but if
I can then take on that five and also
stop my opponent from checkmating me
that feels like a good trade-off despite
the initial hesitancy you might have
about the material that you're giving up
yeah and you're using chess principles
with everything you're saying right
talking about being a coach with your
student which is hey the piece that's
out of the game needs to play and alpha
zero as well is the is the ultimate
proponent of the initiative using
everybody using everybody even at the
cost of the the points so if the rook
has to give itself up for the night but
actually the pieces remaining or more
powerful for black then and sign me up I
guess so this is this is a wild game
super fun I think it's the last game I
want to talk about because I I feel like
this is my game you know I notice just
like every move for black and white here
this is uh what we'll see if we can
continue so now what Robert what do
what's gonna happen next
I mean ninety three I'm anticipating cuz
I don't really see another move also
black can play Queen e2 if you want to
trade Queens you are up upon to begin
with
and I'm liking hard Krishna's position
we've said he's played some great chess
throughout the entire yeah then and it's
true and this game is no exception to
that
no he really has and is exciting chess
to one of the games that he definitely
should one was when he was white in this
same exact pairing he didn't convert as
black though and we have just as dynamic
of an affair a lot of a lot of other not
so dynamic games that's around if I'm
totally honest let's back up for a
second while we let them think and just
quickly flash that video Gujarati does
have an advantage over here against
Levon Aronian with the extra pawn but
still major pieces in the endgame
Danny mess it's not an extra pawn it's
not an extra pawn I meant an extra pawn
because it's passed here in the center
not an extra point we're gonna have to
work on that addition man I'm the guy
who's getting up at like 3:30 a.m. okay
mr. judge emic judger said I'm tired I
mean you know mr. excuse her Steen over
there you know hear that pawn is looking
good it's a passed pawn but that just
goes to show about pawn quality you have
a passed pawn a queen behind it and the
King on h8 I talked with us earlier in
the case of men game now there might be
back Frank checkmates that keep blacks
forces tied to his own first rank yep
you
okay so maybe maybe it's actually little
bit harder for LaVon then then I realize
even though he's not down upon math
confirmed but it is tricky right you
want to find two things you want to find
a way to get pressure on the deponent
for your back rank so the goal is simple
at least
and what happens in the meantime
by the way another draw this round who
drew Irina has already drawn maryam Uzi
Chuck
Irina crush excuse me it's a full names
I'm watching for Queen 66 now in this
game that we're looking at that's and
that's like we're eating four stops it
and and combining the threat of the
d-pod running along with maybe a
switcheroo ski to the seventh rank here
you should show that Danny so b5 at
rookie seven Queen 65 is a blunder
because rookie eight is check and you
distract the rook away
the King has no escape and that's a key
point as to why Queenie four was played
so quickly by vidit I think this is an
idea he spied the moment LaVon plate
aged six everyone is now the Queen
guarding this square is what makes that
threat possible if the Queen was on any
other square that's not a threat so
actually the bulletin you know he's got
his work cut out for him rookie sevens a
real threat along with d6 this is this
is tricky
interesting that we talked about you
know what a tough pairing it was for
someone struggling in the event like
that it has been and LaVon who's been an
absolute stud a star so like I said
maybe it's a game that will poke the
bear a little bit but did it playing a
very good a very good game right now and
I just I mean I had put you on the spot
here Danny which I do often and I said
all right is this closer to a win for a
white or is black closer to holding what
would you say I think it's closer to a
win for white
right now I might like my gut tells me
that it should be closer to black being
able to hold but given the practical
elements of such a position I would have
to agree with you well right now I think
that this position with d6 and rookie 7
coming makes it really hard there's no
way to deal with the concrete threats
without I guess further kind of
extending your structure almost I'm
looking at f5 but I mean ok the reason
when I first came to this I was pressing
it well not a lot of excitement over the
other board is because I did I did the
kind of superficial you know major
pieces versus major pieces is the deep
one really gonna be enough but then the
more the more the concrete elements are
revealed it looks hard for black to deal
with these threats
that's true but White's King is also not
the you know as well defended either
it's not gonna be a Czech Manning attack
but when I see a pawn configuration like
this with a cherry g2 very nice you
called it yeah and I want to get a queen
c1 Queen up for you drawing the arrows
of frightening the said this is what
waking up I'm tired of the blunders I've
been making here I'm just you know been
a little tired a little distracted but
yeah this idea is very clear and this is
exactly the pawn structure you look for
a perpetual check-in right but because
the Queen is so well centered on e4 that
prevents that kind of drawing mechanism
from being a thing and I'm wondering
though how is white going to push
forward because if you play d6 now the
rook on d8 can't capture because of back
rank checkmate still so that that's a
good move in the sense that you're not
blundering a pawn away but maybe that
makes blacks life a little bit easier
and since it now your D pawn can
eventually become an issue but
ultimately this Queen on e4 keeping that
King stuck on the back rank is so
essential yeah and and by the way you
mentioned d6 being a threat if you get
another move and there isn't a Queen c7
check then then the bond pushes again
right so this is this is just very
tricky Queen c7 was a good move as far
as at least poking at the potential
problems in white structure but Bennett
video will we'll try to find an accurate
way to expand and maybe I was wrong you
know I said that maybe black is closer
you know objectively should be closer to
holding but the more moves that are
played and d6 on the agenda I'm gonna
take my words back and say this just
looks phenomenal Robert you're never
wrong you're just always giving me an
opportunity to learn a lesson at least
you're learning but let's go let's go
back you're never losing if you're
learning I always say and that that's a
pep talk that guys like me I've had to
give themselves a lot of times all right
here we go back to the Yan Christophe
Duda matchup versus and tell the Hari
Christian of the exchange sack occurred
the G file is open I just love Harvey's
position here this is here comes the
Knight to e4 well don't go 94 now
because Brook takes that five check is a
tactical one very nice
so
what a weird position right Hari is on
the clock let me just show the tactic
you were you were highlighting
yep right this is approximately and even
even then I would say black should be
okay yeah we don't like then he plays 96
yeah that's a smart move
I was gonna guess that makes sense bring
the knight out first and you're still
not exactly threatening 94 because of
your threat but you pointed out well
that the Knights just if they dominate
the lie scores black is black is okay in
a lot of weird material imbalances this
is one of those positions where the the
math says and we know I'm not good at
math we've established that today but
the math says white you know has the
rook should be better in terms of the
chess points but but the Knights are the
ones dominating the critical action in
the center ninety-six threatens f4 by
the way you have anything for a rook is
better than a knight and two bonds
you're asking me yeah you said buy
points that why should be better so I'm
asking you if you think of rook is more
valuable than the 92 bonds well I was
just pointing out the exchange imbalance
right I mean the the f5 pawn could fall
and break unit 5 now is probably a
decent choice okay and he does it yeah
with the site I mean tonight only has
one pollen and with the exchange in
balance that's what I'm saying is like
you think why should be better maybe
what will be better I don't know but it
feels like the knight should be able to
outplay them when they control all these
squares and by taking Knight 64 you you
still have the second you get a second
pawn back for that exchange and also
White's King is not so happy but blacks
King for sure is not happy either in the
case of Knight takes d5 where it's
forcing why should before Queen D for
Brooke f2
I don't want to allow an immediate draw
with King each one Queen h4 check and
they're really pins from both sides yeah
crazy work f2 you'd love to play Knight
g4 but the knight is pinned the rook
even if it's pin can still do a little
pinning of his own
yeah hmm a wild one a wild one
yeah I actually don't know who's better
here I mean your point about just now
that f5 pawn is gone and being able to
double on the F file and also there's
some sneaky variations where if your
rook moves out the way with that rook F
to the Queen come to h7 yep yeah I love
that idea the rook goes to F to the
knight is pinned and suddenly this might
be a threat yeah I think I think we're
gonna head back over to the firoozeh
hikaru game not sure what happened over
there
but firoozeh does manufacture the e pawn
forward with it maybe an advantage
hey Cara was focused and zoned in there
but this is as scary as any positions
he's had since the vichy and on game
right maybe in the entire event and for
those who didn't see that game yesterday
Hikaru was undeniably in big trouble but
really held on and then joined us in an
interview but this one this one looks
like some pressure is is facing Nakamura
that's a great pun it's sort of like the
vid upon where it maybe even material
but it's hard to notice that one after F
takes G six I have a nice advance Paul
my rook on the seventh rank so the black
King not safe either there's actually
interesting overlap between these two
games yeah
and you've got these two points here
which you know and so if you miss play
it and and and eat and the e-pawn falls
these two points will be nasty but maybe
firoozeh considers the trade now if you
take d5 and trade it for East six in the
end blacks King still has some some
things to worry about
that's a good point because sometimes
people are afraid to give up their past
pawn thinking that no I need to keep
that at all costs otherwise my advantage
is totally gone but you're a hundred
percent correct that because of blacks
king lack of safety that even that trade
there it opens up a new diagonal for the
White Queen yeah it could be things like
Queen a5 also you could also go for the
as you said the diagonal it's a position
where despite the the material close to
equality you shouldn't underestimate
that if this C point eventually Falls
which though it's past it's also
isolated isolated this this does offer
good winning chances as an endgame the
night the night endgame even has outside
chances the knight and rooks can create
a lot of problems so if you're looking
at this position it is a little scary
for Recaro because if everything
transitions whether I get something
against the king or not as firoozeh at
the C pawn Falls white still has winning
chances yeah also another good point
then in Knight end games an extra pawn
yeah tends to really be a struggle
especially with Knight and rook
combinations so I think that a car was
done a good job of fending off all the
races those pawns on f5 and E 5 scared
me earlier but I do believe that white
is better and has a pretty safe
advantage most importantly yeah
interesting well he is down on the clock
I guess the one thing we haven't really
pointed out is that that critical moment
earlier where faroush it took 6 minutes
kind of surprised us that's an
understatement if you missed it but that
he hasn't really recovered on on on time
so that's definitely gonna be something
Hikaru can maybe press a little bit
we'll see if fruga can continue to find
good moves despite being under time
pressure Daniel I wanted just to mention
and give a shout out to Wesley so yeah
cuz he's about to win for Team USA Wow
yeah let's see what their real quick the
trade of the D for the e pawn does
indeed occur Wesley so as black
is uh is about to beat Jorge Cory he's
up to pawns to start with and you know
if you take just funnin III then I can
probably queen seats you check and
things like that and the very least
black remains up a clear pawn yeah maybe
even two pawns but it's not a it's not
good for white that's for sure and the
bishop probably better than the night
unless the unless the outside dream of a
Batman and Robin dynamic duo Jack made
attack happens the Queen and Knight not
really the better duo than the Queen and
Bishop and an open board endgame like
this so so Corey only two minutes on the
clock
down a pole and as you said I will to it
too to start wow what a day for Wesley
cell right he drew earlier against
Sergey Karjakin the hold that USA needed
and if he wins this Team USA is in great
shape to stay in second place I was
worried that we held him too long in the
interview and he wouldn't have time to
get in playing shape but he's clearly
showing good chess in this game and
Danny I think you inspired him you gave
him the good juju game that you good you
Jews you know nothing like reconnecting
with family help by the way let's go
back to a corner of Rouge it they've
drawn so interesting for Russia plays
Queen d3 and offered a draw which I
think that's what happened I don't I
don't I don't actually trying to scroll
back through the chat to see who offered
the draw before I make this statement
it's a little hard to find it was a very
busy chat a lot of people watching the
game over on chess calm so okay well I
don't know who offered the draw but they
did agree to it
maybe we overestimated peruses potential
advantage although are you are you a
little surprised that the game ended
here I am surprised
but now that they have agreed in a draw
that's information for me to use
I guess Queen to b2 is the move that
fruit was anticipating the f2 pawn is a
target and if I play move like night to
d2 we just trade everything on D to get
into a working game which would just
well that I guess yes sorry I was just I
was trying to get him up getting too
fast I knew I was blundering but the
okay queen bee too I guess
well alright well I mean again a
shout-out to Bakura we still don't know
what happened earlier this game has just
had us flummox so I mean it seems like
we maybe didn't have the the thread on
this game from the beginning or or the
players you know maybe maybe had some
weird chances that weren't taken
advantage of but either way this game
ultimately ends in peace not the worst
result for Hikaru and Team USA because
drawing is black puts them in a great
spot especially if Wesley so takes care
of business over here did oh I see hit
karu in the chat he goes I played the
wrong move order obviously e5 first not
B takes e5 ok so it makes us feel a
little better Hikaru normally as you
know I'm wrong for a living but we were
we were definitely flummoxed obviously
Accardo in chat and we were and but the
move order was interesting for Russia
took a bunch of time and didn't take
advantage of it and this Senate of being
a weird game from start to finish
that's right and Alireza trusted akaru
of course we tend to trust a car too but
we were just you know scratching our
heads wondering can't you just take that
pawn on e6 and go for it but thankfully
for you know USA fans Wesley shows in
such good shape in this game that they
didn't need her car to play the perfect
game they just needed that result out of
him and the car continues to be a great
board one for the American squad as he
hasn't lost a single game and you can't
you know you get stressed just how
important that is because you know that
one loss and a four board lineup that
can just lose the team match immediately
as you can as you saw there on the left
what the scoreboard was there Irina
crusher has already drawn her game which
means the only two left are Wesley snows
battled that he's about to win and let's
go over to Fabia no car Juana's game
versus the good doctor of a semi mean
this one has a little bit more on
clearness to it but Fabiana looks like
he's he's maybe on the verge of an
attack as Bishop takes h5 a threat you
know my voice gets high when I doubt
myself it does look like it's an option
at some point because the G pawn is
pinned and how has this happened we I
thought that it was going to be some
sort of strategic battle yeah now it's
getting all tactical up it happened I
got I got one move right but if we left
it all the way back here when Knight f1
was played and yes you said we were
looking for that strategic kind of
Knight maneuver right so I'm gonna go
through and you pause me when you see
something you don't like me of oh look
what okay
I love exchange sacrifices but I wasn't
expecting that one as Sheboygan
Wisconsin okay well horray decides to
sack exchange I don't know what happened
there but it looks like it was okay for
Fabiano and then he turns on the the
thrusters up the Kings side weird gate
in that Bishop on g7 and what and they
woke up six another exchange sac double
exchange sac double kill
six that was a move I love that hitting
the night f7 is undermined if you move
it obviously the bishop kind of has to
take it but here comes the attack for
white Bishop takes h5 Knight takes e4
right back atcha he says so if if you
you could trade Queens here but I guess
busts Emma means claiming that in these
end games there are chances for him to
hold here despite maybe being down a
pawn but I like white chances this looks
good for fun I could take g6 take b8 and
take efore right is that just if I just
being to wait for word you could also
take b8 take you for takes c5 so you
have your options about yeah maybe your
idea is even better take take take and
bake the D pawn is good although h3
Falls so that's true maybe that was what
must have calculated you could also take
and give a little check because you do
have a little dance on e4 to do well
that's and so King g8 only move in
Knight takes e4 and that King isn't big
trouble over there that looks way better
Danny no that's that's good you've
redeemed yourself my friend don't speak
so soon Queen weight h4 though does look
good I'm guessing a few moves it's funny
because Queen h4 ideas were totally off
my radar like I was taking bishop g6
trade Queens but you when you have
attacking on the brain like you do all
the time it's really helpful in a
position like this Queen h4 also I have
to admit when I first saw this idea it's
because I was fantasizing about some
checkmate idea which of course would be
horrible because the Queen g3 but the
second time I look at it I realized it
was winning tonight so you're right to
call me out the first idea I had was
mate but it looks like it will be good
if Fabiana go so that looks very forcing
by the way there's no there's no other
moves so if Fabiana wants this position
he shall have it yeah and is there some
kind of rook takes e4 Queen g3 check I
don't think so alright whoa
what a move mr. Hess is there i'm
summonin rook f1
there might be I'm worried that black is
gonna checkmate is I'm going to join to
give myself an option with a queen g3
check in the right moment no it's it's a
really good option right queen g3 if I
go this way Bishop takes oh I just have
queen g2 aha
so it's probably fine right I'm the
queen e3 check and I mean give some
checks but not enough I feel sorry I
thought we were I'll show that no you're
good you're good
I think we kind of just we got the point
across but there may be some checks in a
position like this but I don't see
enough to warrant the sacrifice with
maybe king of seven and like you someone
just play on down exchange but I don't
know I don't believe in it but Fabi goes
for it we'll see if boss M believes it
is his last chance to sack the exchange
it's a it's a very tricky position
because you don't find that move I mean
f7 is coming next night g5 is coming
this is very very tough by the way Grand
Master Wesley so we'll stay right here
but Wesley so does indeed convert on his
game vs. Jorge Cory this is the white
player resigns here so Wesley so getting
a huge w to follow the car Nakamura and
Irina crushes draws and M USA continues
to roll team Europe who hasn't gotten a
ton of attention this round the game
with the Levon and vidit has
transitioned to a rock ending re Krishna
and and young Christophe Duda also in
the endgame now
maxine bhashya the Grove and Vishwanath
on an island did draw their game so but
video was you know we thought he was in
the verge of a victory in that one
against Levon Aronian but I haven't
checked in in a while let's stay right
here with Fabien Bassam because this
game definitely looks like it's gonna be
the most exciting finish anyway but this
position that I'm showing on the board
between Gujarati and Aronian only white
can win and and how big would that be
forbidded to redeem himself at Team USA
suddenly the biggest vinegars Rafi fan
on the planet because that slows down
Team Europe yes and they're definitely
really permitted and for him you know
he's had a very tough event but if he
can beat Levon Aronian that's a victory
that you cherish for the rest of your
life kind of like me just Redemption you
know a lot of blunders and you find one
tactic and Robert forgives you that's
okay no but seriously this looks great I
mean one thing to point out everybody is
if it wins these pawns this is not one
of those n games as a draw with like
split pawns this is an easily winning
end game with two connected passers so
these pawns being as weak as they are
games grew throughout the great winning
chances so we'll keep an eye on it but
as we said I think the the guys on
camera Fabiano looks like he's the right
tactic away from probably putting the
good doctor to bed or some good bedside
manner
f7 check your idea Danny and yeah I
heard your joke when I chose her to
train here I'm doing my best alright
but f7 check right that's just f7 check
looks good
because what is that black king think
think it's escaping - lets see it takes
there you can you can do a lot of things
you can bring the rook in you can you
can play check on h7 first I think that
that looks to be best you can go 9 g5
check that g5 chance oh yeah but
actually the line you're about to show
was better and I see the engine bar drop
so my line is bad queen h7 check King f8
I mean there's I think this is this well
he's not much time for bus Sam so he
said go quickly queen it whoa Queen age
six was played and that we didn't that
seem pretty good wow I love how simple
it was Queen age SIG's just checkmate
and one we're looking for f7 and that
was my bad I was guy I threw it out
there
Queen h6 just can't stop when g7
and quite the day here on the feed HHS
comm online nation's Cup let's go back
to this rook ending and see what happens
with video Gujarati and Levon Aronian
obviously it could be instructive a lot
of rook endings are for those who watch
these to get better but there's more
than 27,000 of you right now
wow we got a lot of people here thanks
for being here and we appreciate
wherever you're tuning in from chess TV
twitch YouTube or one of the
aforementioned periscope Facebook mixer
can I combine those three into a single
word somehow you knowing you'll try para
doesn't you'll be able to nope nope okay
no dude right as I said that LaVon shook
his head on camera as if he heard me
[Laughter]
nose
vidit Opie right now for the wind and
this would be a really tough one for
Team Europe put them trailing Team USA
heading into the last day
again the
the scoreboard will be updated there
momentarily we see some of you asking
about that there we go there the results
are coming in so but if Team USA looks
like they're yeah they've already beaten
they've already beaten
[Music]
excuse me team world so uh so they're
gonna be in clear second heading into
the the last day tomorrow Robert yeah
especially with this game and how hard
Christians playing ins Duda it seems
like India has found their form a little
bit too late
indeed and they had some bad luck
earlier vidit had some positions that
were okay he also had some tough tough
games running into a Fabi on great form
so you're right Team India finding their
form but it is too little too late
we're gonna stay right here with LaVon
and and Gujarati but quickly show you
that Hari Krishna probably not in any
position to lose this is now all the
sudden a great exchange sac with such an
active King and a past deep on black
should be should be doing just fine as
this one closes out so yeah Team India
rising rising to the occasion here
toward the end of the event
and LaVon shakes his head vidit we can
barely see em be so locked into this
game here and one good thing that
everybody should take note of is that
did it spawn remains on a six because
sometimes you need your king to snake in
you know in front of the pawn and in
rooks shoulder off the other rook and
then be able to promote because if you
say put your pond a seven and had your
work on a eight for y I know that's a
little hard to conceptualize but having
the rook in front of the pond can be
quite bad you know some of these end
games when the black rook will sit
behind it no it's a great point of it
all kind of dragons you see so if the
rook was here the pawns here all you
need is the rooks sitting behind the
pawn and White's dead stuck because in a
lot of those positions your king is
never really threatening progress you
can just be checked away and there's
nowhere for your King to hide as the
rook and pawn take those squares so
Robert highlighting something that's
very important the fact that you have a
shield means that you can't eventually
escape checks and then slowly kind of
enter your way forward with the pawn and
King on the a file so Gustav the only
has a minute I mean that is so the only
way this gets blown Robert is him kind
of getting down on time and kind of self
imploding
but this should be a win even with the
awkwardness now of the king being cut
off on the G file yeah in the king will
try to make its way back towards that
pawn at some point but there's the big
issue is that black has just a king in a
rook and you're stuck do I stop the H
pawn do I stop the a pawn right and this
is an example of where having rook pawns
are so useful because the pawns are so
far away from each other that black will
never be in time to stop both so what do
you do now do you play a seven just to
force the the rook over and then when
you guard it would check your King is
free the G file can't be guarded along
with the a pawn at the same time or or I
slowly maneuver my inch my king up the
board teenage 5h4
King age six age five pull my Brooke on
g6 free my king on the G file okay yeah
I like that I like that even better so
we'll see what vid it comes up with here
again just taking his time to convert it
he goes with your plan I wonder if he's
a lack of confidence though because this
is type of thing where you feel like you
should be winning but then you're like
oh I hope I don't make a mistake well
LaVon still playing so confidently kind
of keeps him like a little a little
worried
looks like we may have some answers to
our daily question we asked you earlier
for those of you who don't follow the
official chess Stockholm Twitter account
you can do so use the hashtag nation's
cup to follow all the action on social
media and we'll we'll get through some
of those daily questions here in a
moment so we appreciate you playing
along the question was what other
factors go into a team captains decision
not just in terms of fielding a complete
roster who do you pick but also the way
you put them on the boards you know I
think there is something to it right
there's those that are mentally tougher
those that are more resourceful you
think those that are maybe faster and so
maybe you think about specific matchups
and so invite you to get involved use
the hash tag Nations Cup and if you have
a great answer you'll get a diamond
membership and speaking of specific
matchups Danny it's great to see how
many fun playing some chess in winning
against Alexander coriaci can though and
you know she's showing that her hiatus
is not going to stop her from excelling
and I mean just what a fantastic player
we heard Wesley so his thoughts about
her earlier today and she continues to
win games important ones for Team China
we're gonna stay right here the only
other game still going right now is
actually hope he can arrows game versus
on a on a Moosa Chuck we'll stay right
here with Vidya and LaVon but yeah
before we let you go today we will
quickly show you how Howie fun got
another victory let's just say that the
rest of the ladies in the chest world
maybe don't miss her Robert I think they
probably miss her in the sense that
everybody loves seeing the best players
compete just like you know if Magnus
Carlsen retired everyone be like wait
where'd that guy go
I know I would be devastated to see that
happen so I do think you know when Garry
Kasparov retired people they missed here
they still wanted to play he's captain
team Europe's like hey Gary get out
there go play board one for Team Europe
but Yvonne she's fantastic she's you
know studying these days but clearly her
chest has not suffered too much
indeed and if she decided to come back
I'm sure she would be a very very
welcome welcome acquisition to the world
of competitive chess so
check and now the threat every one of a
eight makes this over Levon Aronian
resigns vinegar Rashi Google and given
the fist pumps they're given the emotion
so excited to get out of the cellar he
out plays one of the hottest players in
the event I mean I don't think that can
be underestimated that that's not just
that that was a victory but Levon
Aronian has been a man who could not be
stopped since round one right and and
vidit vidit made him halt in his tracks
I just I'm speechless after seeing video
with the fist pump it must feel so good
after several tough days you're doubting
yourself you're feeling like you're
letting your team down your country down
and then video gets a huge win over
Levon Aronian there and just it must be
a huge sigh of relief I can play chess
with a very pretty fighters in the world
yeah it feels like that sometimes like
you literally just forget how to win
games but video Gujarati does it we are
back over in the young Christoph do -
Bella vs. patellar hari krishna and it's
it's probably still the most exciting
one left to finish although let's check
in on a game that hasn't gotten any
attention real quick Wang Hao and
Vladislav artemyev should draw this
position yeah looks like we're just
gonna have a couple of nights sacrifice
for a couple of pawns and there you go
and word was that our team was winning
earlier in this match and nah okay
interesting now it's a draw
she didn't at least make black work a
little harder with the King g6 King G
seventh right now that it's just to show
everybody real quick not that it's not
an easy draw but you can go in and hope
for some sort of like you know I don't
know it's always a check but I don't
know whatever he doesn't try that's the
point
here we go draw that's for the next game
oh man you thank you for your very
astute point there but I know what
you're saying that love is already on h6
it isn't win but I mean okay like the
Knights don't do well guarding corner
pawns that was my point I was trying to
make and you're right you're not wrong
let's put it that way but it's the world
Hari Christian now with the advantage
against young Christophe Duda despite
the fact that we have even number of
pawns but black's pawn is more advanced
it's like d2 right now isn't the only
way you stop it by sacrificing use that
takes back on b5 but d2 it is the huge
threat
yeah this is uh it seems like a super
hard position for white to play less
than a minute the threat of d2 is real
we're investing Wesley so in the chest
comm Chad says there's no real chance
for black to win this though it's only a
draw
yeah rookie six check is probably a
useful moods to kick the King out from
e3 and then maybe bring the White King
over at the king f1 and stop that pawn
before it can get too far if this game
ends in peace perhaps it's poetic but
these two guys have given us a real
fight not a game that we necessarily
thought would end this way but they both
played very well in a crazy game a game
that magically one side was down a piece
at some point but then they weren't
I got nothing in Robert there okay no I
was distracted I was distracted for a
change just checking out the chat so I
pulled to you you should be proud of me
Wesley so hanging out in the chest comm
chat again you can head over on your
mobile app one of the fun things about
following the games on the app is you
can very easily watch the games and
actually toggle along with the live chat
I was kidding before when I said me and
Wesley have some of our deepest talks
but only partly he is my dad now we do
bond regularly and chatting on chest
comm is one way we do it
for sure nook te8 by JKD trying to get
the rook behind the past pawn with a
check and yeah feels like black doesn't
really have any weight chances anymore
that i can see in fact has some losing
chances because if your pawn has stopped
and I still have my Jeep on I might try
to support that one up the board
it plays d2 which means white has the
option to to check in sack if the King
goes anywhere but III so if the King
goes to III if you want you can
literally end the game with tickle right
away rook out three rook f2 maybe maybe
just whole bunch of checks or or or work
back to e8 but after King III when I
just King F one your pawn has stopped oh
yeah I mean no now you have to be super
careful this is it's getting getting
awkward and rookie to chuck is a pretty
nasty threat and Hari is down on the
clock now
and this could be huge for Team Europe
and I know I spent saying he were huge a
lot Wow I'm gonna stop saying that but
this could be a much-needed game this
could reach above average size for game
Europe
yes exactly Danny you throwing in a few
qwerty synonyms there three so the ninth
great what a great move actually the
knight has to the knight is to give up
the D pawn
young Chris I don't quite know why I
mean it looks like he's playing well
and both Blair's shaking hands so
there's something that neither player
likes here but white is taking this deep
one off the board and then the Jeep on I
said earlier of you and you if I can
stop your deep on and help get my Jeep
on going it's very hard for a rookie
tonight to stop two rooks in the past
bond
you're on Christoph Flay's rook f3
risking the move rook d4 but then even
b4 check as possible and you kind of
force him to give up the deep wallet
okay Black Hills worked before anyway
with only two seconds by the way already
made that move you know it's a bullet
game and this coming 10 second increment
could be enough to get them get them a
little bit of time back on the clock but
likely will be sticking right here for a
while without a lot of time left for
either side Chuck Brooks c4 okay Andrew
oh you see do to shake his head he
didn't see that coming he forgot about
that move because of rooks e4 take back
and then the pawn is closer to queening
Gibbs check we're gonna get King B for
now
Harker's are thinking - you don't want
the king in maybe there's some more pin
yeah baby you could go the other way
because you can't take b5 right away
that seems like a weird move to play but
I mean now I have rook a to coming over
here i king b6 is weird but he wants to
get his team closer to the Jeep on he's
worried that one becomes a runner his
king can help out in the defense okay
interesting
okay so is 94 getting me made it after
some kind of rookie six check rook
nobody okie seven so that's the problem
is white wants to create this staircase
for the checkmate but it feels like
black is just in time to prevent that
from happening
Keeney seven year of rooks e6 wow that's
a that's a tough trade right the rook is
so much better than the night in these
race positions but I guess the King's
supportive you can sacrifice your knight
for the Jeep on and use the King to
support the b-pawn then you may be
finding yourself in the night is just so
so inept when it comes to stopping past
pause so it's scary I'm actually not
sure if this should be a win for white
or somehow and be whole but it feels
like white should win based on their
rope being so much stronger the knight
the Knights gonna take maybe he'll play
rook b6 or just start pushing here we go
and it's a true race
but you can keep five she didn't you
can't go g42 soon because then 95
hitting the pond G for after a night of
three check when the pond what his idea
the night goes to e5 and if g5 we get a
fork on f3 okay that's key now you can
push King c4 and push again and King c4
can throw in rook c7 if I yet you have
all your King back
well what's weird is King c4 rook c7
King defy view go back then I go back
okay well 95 maybe even better than
that's just so that's a good move but
it's scary right because the nights on
the edge of the board I was gonna say
that might be a move you walk back but
that's the point is the rook only is
those two squares b7 and b8 and the
knight is chasing it off the B file very
nice
so you mean Suruga template 95 is gonna
go over a seven if it King be sick
I love how much I have a question there
was yeah I don't know I mean keen knight
c6 if rook b7 now 95 is a draw so do to
kind of give him a bit of a like I don't
really want the draw yet cuz only I can
win so I'm not gonna repeat Team Europe
needs @w
by the way oh I was just gonna say still
going the other game by the way is
finally drawn Team India hum pika narrow
draws on a mu Z chuck it was a rock
ending that was the only other game
still going quickly flashing the final
position there was nothing to it they
repeated with a whole bunch of checks
but this is the one that team Europe
needs
and this is a critical moment for her a
Christian here because when I when I
look here I do I play b3 door play 95 to
stop the Jeep on a sooner do I play King
to d4 to bring my king and to support
the pawn but I'm I just feels like a
position that white should be winning
and there's teetering on the edge here
and he plays b3 after a long think and
rook c1 check but king b5 the King has
cut from the beat punt for the moment so
you can't be too cuz rookie one yeah I
was gonna say that's that that's the key
dysfunction is you're not threatening to
advance so now now you're getting scared
you'd like to play things like ninety
five and come in but this is where the
knight is really gonna get flexed on by
the rook you play like King t4 if check
can I even go to c3 I'm gonna pick up
your pawn and my rook and guard the G
pond I think I think he'd be poor but
even better way to do that but he may he
may be headed to c3 anyway yeah King
before perhaps there was some worry
about came to b4 and just trying to
shoulder your king out but you're right
this is Wesley 73 was a mistake in the
chest calm chat and then he gives him
meow interesting Wesley interest yeah
it's so difficult when the mistake is
pushing your passport right like you're
like that's what I've been told to do I
have a past punished and push it again
g4 there might be some kind of Knight of
694 checked RIA
but after g4 9 f6 your rook g1 just
don't blend to that pond yeah I think he
could have just gone to you for which he
won the king is close enough to stop the
pawn now which means you can you can
switch duties the rook could have looked
could've gone behind the pond I think
you were right on the money there
partner I think that you could have just
switched gears with the rook and just
pushed okay not to say white still isn't
winning but
she's just G for right G for now
re looking a little more frustrated ugh
what a game this was where the key
design of seven I moved 12 or whatever
it was and then Harvey Saxon exchanged
its good position and then in an
up-and-down battle it's been JK d in
this ending well team Europe plays Team
USA tomorrow if I'm not mistaken so
if if if Team Europe holds the draw here
Robert they're still in you know shape
to catch Team USA so this is a huge game
if Duda can win it yes and then
head-to-head matchup will decide who
will finish in the second place and for
Team Europe you know if you can
withstand a loss by Levon Aronian
because JKD can convert this one you're
getting more confidence in your board
three we saw him lose the game earlier
to you yang Jie it was disappointing
affair for him for sure but now after 96
can I not just go king c3 and there's a
plate and the pot is falling goes cheap
on the G pod will be enough don't play
g5 don't play g5 94 check is a fork and
also don't play rook takes e5 thinking
you're winning in the king of auditing
cuz you're not King gets in just in time
if you look at the square the king is
inside the box and yep that would be a
draw okay white why just winning with a
number of other moves including even
like King B - yeah okay he does it that
was that was I think the best and
simplest now you can give a check you
can't even push g5 now yep here we go
and you get one check my king goes to be
one you've no more checks and this is
what someone knowing about a knight a
knight a diagonal way from a king
it takes three moves to give it another
check right it's going ninety one Knight
f3 Knight to d2 just to give it a check
so Knights kind of lack of mobility at
least easy access to the square in front
of it or next to it it shows its ugly
head here Wesley so say a nice game by
Duda turning around a bad pattern around
a bad position so agreed gonna be a
great victory here and again a huge one
for Team Europe keeping their chances
close versus Team USA in the final day
before our super final on Sunday
and okay so Jesus yes yeah cos the check
hardships that and in fact Hari just
resigns indeed Wow you know you know
Danny I think I might have cursed the
Indian team because I said it was you
know talking about didn't we sell the
fist pump to help his team win the match
and then it seemed didn't win the match
so that may be a commentators curse but
it seems a little bit cursed himself in
the event when he lost the team one he
wins the team loses he's finding his
form which makes you happy and hari
again I mean we said this earlier
whether he went on to win or lose this
game has played some of the most
exciting chess and so that part of it is
just been a joint of watch but this game
this game was wild ultimately does not
go the way of Team India so all right
we're gonna take a very very quick break
when we return wrap-up thoughts make
sure we take a quick look at some of the
games that were the most instructive and
interesting and final final moments here
round eight from the feed a chest
combinations Cup in just a couple
minutes
[Music]
and we are back now joined once again by
Grandmaster Fabiano Caruana favi
congratulations on the win and thanks
you so much for for rejoining us for
another interview thank you
now Robert and I were really obsessed
with the right way to convert this game
with f7 check it took you playing queen
aged six on the board for us to realize
just how easy it was yeah it took me a
while to because I was considering 7 or
9 g5 moves like that
my g5 I think between r6 doesn't work
out right absolutely my work but then I
saw the ice between h6 and I realized
that she just resides well jokes aside
about the last position it take us
through if you would I'm gonna scroll
through until you think there's
something spicy to talk about you uh you
obviously get a huge win here as white
what's the opening something you
expected or prepared against vez M amine
or you were just going with the flow
well I knew that he is very loyal to the
Kings indeed offense so I expected this
and I I decided to play a line which is
extremely rare 92 and h3 but it's not so
stupid but after c6 we were both on our
own I was just trying to play quickly
too you have to keep some time on the
clock because I figured the main problem
would come later in the game it seems
like that's been a clear plan of yours
as far as playing very quickly in the
opening so is that a testament to your
solid preparation and just understanding
that maybe the opening won't dictate the
rest of the game or is it just to build
the lead on the clock and hope that that
favors you when the dynamics start
eating up it might be the the third
option which is I don't really feel like
thinking of 8:00 in the morning me the
fourth option which is of course you if
you have to go to the bathroom not this
time buddy
yeah and this a my I figured that it's
really there's not much point in looking
for subtleties early on because the
story is
too complicated to actually figure
things out and the time will be very
important later and I think that's
pretty much what happened in the game
although I felt like I got very good
position in where I completely ruined it
I mean he played this interesting
exchange side okay yeah I don't know mr.
C fathers is debatable decision but I
know that in a lot of these positions
like similar positions quite sets of
lights for blockade it can be extremely
unpleasant for black to get this well we
go there yeah the reason I paused here
is because this was one of the first
moments when Robin and I were commenting
on the game and I wanted to get your
thoughts on Bishop takes e5 because as
you said it was kind of a critical
moment you decide to part ways with the
bishop pair to go for this plan and take
us through the exchange sack because
when it happened here I well I had I had
a I had a pretty obvious reaction on
camera it was a bit surprising to see
Brooke a5 yeah I didn't expect that well
I thought my position was good though I
expected him to take on c4 Queen d6 or
or let me take on on d6 but I understand
it's difficult for black to find what he
would love to get b5 in but he can't
quite do it and I'll plug this should be
fun before that right yeah you can't I
like have this position we work on BA
for example but he can't quite a cheetah
so I understand his thought process but
work a father is a bit extremely also
it's definitely one of the more unique
sacrifices that I've ever seen but it
does force your hand and then I don't
see Ford you know it's worth a lot to
the position so did you feel like after
he played this move somehow his position
became easier to play or did you just
think that you scooped up in exchange
and it just should be good to convert
for you I think he basically puts the
responsibility on me because before he
had to come up with more difficult moves
while my play is very easy and just
trying to fight for the B Foxboro
now I have to decide where to place my
pieces and the most difficult decision
was where to put my knight on because on
c3 it's very poorly placed at all and I
thought the natural squares on d2 but I
couldn't quite find a way to set it up
comfortably so I came up with this I
just played 94 because I thought it
would force them to think
and because of the slight and very
strange
I don't even know what to call it saw
blunders on this calculation I just
thought after Queen I said I could play
Queen g5 and invade on e7 and I didn't
for some reason to see that he can just
play rook e8 and stop me in my tracks
and this doesn't really go anywhere for
me so so I probably shouldn't put my leg
on that board I should probably have
played so now I might be one and and
then trying to set up my pieces Queenie
392 all right I probably should almost
weren't even thinking because it looks
very natural but yeah and I before was
probably not a bad truth I'm not a good
choice then I think he played well he
says yeah I saw no better place to my
knight and here I wasn't to stop this
race sex but of course I do we can like
kingside enormous league with chief war
um and then was sort of based off on
this calculation which is I thought I
didn't see that he had a queen be a and
again so you saw this line was coming
but you didn't see this move yeah I mean
Queens don't like a t5 and t6 with tempo
and for some reason Queen being evaded
my attention I'm suddenly not only five
Niner five d6 Revere my Center is kind
of crumbling and I might work out first
I don't think I have some weight which
one of yous ever d6 what would black
play here you think rook e8 okay and
then I don't know I was looking at
things like they should be fought here
in 94 it looks it look like a complete
mess 94 Bishop e5 like queen of three
yeah I don't think that it's easy for
him either but I also thought I might be
risking
significantly if I wanted to this right
though so I okay yeah this quick d3 I
think was interesting I mean he
shouldn't have a lab workups this was a
very serious mistake of me maybe he only
saw his exchange sacrifice earlier in
the game and missed that you would do
the same in return
yeah I I don't know if he overlooked or
gripstics or P or estimated maybe he
thought that he would have something
after take take so what do you think he
should have played here instead of well
I think the obvious choice to take on c3
take on e4 Queen III and
and my g3 and I think that he has a good
position but I don't think he's better I
should probably let work up - I thought
he can't live here he can psyche upset
because a dog isn't the end of the world
cream well but I didn't think I was
working so and I thought when I kind of
thought I might have to go through this
sort of thing he'll I already I already
felt like I completely lost my advantage
and I should start looking for bailouts
so he misses it and then you you return
to the exchange sack favor very nice
idea obviously if the knight moves and
f7 falls so blacks hand is kind of
forced and then did you think you were
winning at this point now well I didn't
see anything better for him than what he
did yeah
and I just had a difficult choice after
94 because he yeah mr. G 6fg
and here I had to decide between the
queen bee it which looks like a winning
that game to me yeah 94 I'm a pawn in my
past balls very strong or Queen h4 like
I played oh I thought not to create
working g94 he has to like yesterday
going for click Queen g3 and I thought
that should be winning yeah we actually
looked at this in the game and saw you
at Queen Chi 2 and thought that he would
just kind of run out of checks well here
I thought maybe I was trying to avoid
this well I'm gonna play Queen up to
first instead of King each one and then
Queen g5 now King gauge 1 and that'll be
the fish to fire I have I have working
one Wow
okay I thought all his comfortable yeah
so he doesn't go rookie for said Queenie
five and then a lot of calculation was
going into this we're like how does
Bobby finish it off and then
you know makes a the world number 2
player to find Queen h6 apparently
sometimes I know the thing is I really
was looking first at other options and
Queen h6 didn't didn't occur to me until
like a few minutes thought into yeah
that's all I play with them within like
two seconds because right well Fabi what
we have you will take a breath back here
from the chess way to go on another good
day for Team USA you guys are now in
clear second place chasing China it's
kind of a race for a second place at
this point I mean let me just ask first
how impressed have you been with Team
China and and their consistency on every
board I'm not surprised at all it is
quite impressive and I mean they every
board they have strong I mean obviously
Taylor and is extremely good to have on
first floor he's both very solid and he
picks up
he picks up wins I mean he's a great
team player as well as being a great
individual player you yang Yi is kind of
winning all those games so that also
helps their cost and they have in
general a very big advantage on for for
pony phone is I named a number one
ranked four in the world so it's that's
what I've been looking to score big plus
on that board as well
Fabiano Yu yang Yi did very well in the
st. Louis rapid and blitz last year when
he played and do you think he's a bit
underestimated in these Rapids on
patrols
I don't know I don't really know because
it's difficult to to say what
underestimated means I mean everyone
knows that he's a top player but I guess
he flies a bit under the radar compared
to to some of the more established top
players but that doesn't mean that he
can't beat anyone in the world on a
given day or have I guess part of my
question is you know in classical chess
is rating did take a bit of a tumble so
how do you as a top player look at
players who may be struggling in
classical chess and then adjusting to
recognize that rapid and blitz are just
a kind of a totally different ballgame
well I didn't really feel like grabbing
a blitz is sort of more of an equalizer
like like the difference in strength
becomes less visible in general that's
my feeling but I guess that could also
be argued I think also that the
difference between let's say the number
or the world in the number 25 of the
world 2 is really down to very very
small details and it might not even
sometimes be chess related it might be
psychology it might be a lot of a lot of
factors I go into into the difference
between you know let's say 20 places in
the world and in rapid and woods you
know some sort of that stuff go so go
out the window and you have players who
are equally skilled equally skilled in
chess pretty much yeah but you're
mentioning some of these X factors I
think in terms of what makes a great
chess player the psychology and maybe
some of the different mental mental
makeups of people that aren't just about
the chess it makes me want to ask you
real quick Bobby the daily question as
we let you go here if you were a team
captain and you mentioned you young you
being a great teammate but what do you
think goes into someone who does really
well in these types of team events is it
obviously being a strong chess player
right that helps it is a chess game but
are there other things about the mental
makeup of people that you think do
better in team events
oh I don't really know because you have
teams that what they are very closely
knit very good friends like let's say
Armenia was was winning I think they
want to only be heads in a row and
they're all you know a very close team
over and friendly and you have teams
where maybe that's not as much of a
factor but still they do very well so I
don't know if that really makes the
difference
I think in general it does help to not
put too much pressure on yourself
thinking about the team result I mean in
general keep late they will relax them
and you don't worry about what your
teammates are thinking or or what your
captain if your captain is worried about
your game and just take the pressure off
of it I think that does help
makes sense I don't really have any
other questions Fabi again thank you so
much for for taking us through the chest
and for being an awesome an awesome
interview here so best of luck to Team
USA on the final day you guys have a
head-to-head matchup against Team Europe
do you do you know if you'll be in the
lineup you expect to play tomorrow play
sorry dad I was just gonna say you
played Team Europe and team China so you
know that your destinies in your own
hands I'm sure that makes you feel
better about your chances right because
you control all the options here well
early on in the event I thought that we
it's really a long shot when we I got
back to the first few days it seemed
like we weren't doing too well I thought
it was a real long shot that we're
finished talked to but now I mean out to
today the situation has improved really
dramatically at home and I think that
we're we're probably sign papers to
finish talked to but of course it is
going to be very close I really just
come down to the match against hero
claiming that that will be I remember we
decide to post it in my cradle
well optimistic about Team USA chances I
think a lot of people are with the small
lead over Europe but like Robert said
best of luck in the head-to-head
matchups against Europe and China and
maybe we'll be catching up with you on
Sunday yeah sure thanks Bobby yeah once
again a great interview with Fabiano
Caruana he's awesome
always appreciate his time and going
through not just the chest but just his
thoughts on stuff he gave a lot of
thoughts about the different things that
make up a strong chess player sometimes
it's not always just the X's and O's he
didn't really think of you young Yi as
an underdog necessarily Robert but he's
a top player who of course has tons in
respect for him I think as far as the
fans go maybe they're just not really
expecting you young e to be as good as
he is but anyway the team captains
certainly knows how good he is that's
why he's been in the lineup let's see
what some of the responses were at Seoul
Anais 1 3 they inspire those around them
and always put the team first that
sounds uh sounds like you Robert
I appreciate it down I'll take this one
hi XTO says a player's ability to play
different styles are able to go
aggressive when the team needs a win or
play solidly to hold for a draw
understanding when to push for the win
or to take the draw is a must I love
that answer here because you know if
you're down in the standings like Team
Europe is versus Team USA and you're
playing them you say wait we may need a
win and a loss is the same as a team
draw so we need to put in the player who
feels give us the most chances and as
you see the captains there well for
Europe it's Gary Kasparov he really
needs no introduction we say that often
but I don't think Gary kiss borrow along
with Magnus Carlsen Bobby Fischer the
best-known chess players of all time
and then for Team USA John Donaldson as
we compared those teams vying for second
place JD has been around for a long time
captaining Team USA has won many medals
and has made very good decisions along
the way indeed and we'll we'll see what
kind of decisions they make in this
final day it'll be interesting because I
think no matter what we'll we'll have
something to talk about in terms of who
they decide to put in the lineup and why
it makes you think we'll probably get
the same kind of players we've had today
because at least for Team Europe and
Team USA it seems like their best
lineups are kind of being established
but but who knows we'll see but Gary
Kasparov and John Donaldson who have the
biggest heat on them as far as captains
and the decisions they make going into
Saturday do so alright well Robert it's
been it's been another another exciting
day here awesome chess and your final
thoughts before we let people go on what
you expect to happen tomorrow with Team
USA versus Team Europe head-to-head
battle give it give us a little bit of a
preview
it's a tough one to preview because
Levon Aronian was off to a blistering
pace in these middle rounds winning
three games in a row but he then got
stopped in his tracks like videos Rafi
so we'll see if Levon is able to bounce
back as well as Maxine but sure the
graph at the top of that Team Europe
line up but dunker Stubb Duda you must
be making garriga's farm happy they're
on board three is that's been the board
that we have been concerned about they
lost earlier today against China on that
board
but don't just look at Team USA vs. Team
Europe because let's say that match is a
tie then USA has to go up against China
in the final round and well no matter
who else you played play in the final
round of this event it's going to be
easier matchup than playing against Team
trynna which isn't a first so I think
USA with a tough road ahead it's going
to be a struggle but as Fabiano said he
likes his chances I like the way Fabiano
Caruana
Wesley so at Karan Nakamura Irina
crushed that four player lineup has been
doing wonders for Team USA and if with
all due respect to Leonard Dominguez and
on asset on ski just feels like that's
where Jon Donson has to go he's to rely
on those four and hope they can push
this team to the Super Final agreed and
we would we would expect those lineups
we'll see you be interested if a nice
giri gets back in on board three for
team europe and what team captain garry
kasparov comes up with tonight but
either way we've got the schedule in
front of you one last time reminder of
course we'll be here yet again saturday
the weekend is here and then on Sunday
we will have a Super Final between China
likely and another team of course crazy
things have happened before China could
suffer their last two matches losses
again you know
but even if they lose their last two
matches they still I don't I was
actually gonna say and then actually we
they would they would still be tied and
actually still win no the only USA can
catch them there are five points ahead
of Europe so they are in the super final
regardless right well that's the story
and we will we will have it all tomorrow
we'll see what happens really gonna come
down to Team USA and Team Europe
exciting stuff so make sure you're there
tune in 6:00 a.m. Pacific 9:00 a.m.
Eastern and like we said a different
time zone is 1500 c est I'm not gonna go
through all those right now I am just
gonna say thank you to the whole team
working hard to make this event happen
and we will see you tomorrow for rounds
9 and 10 of the feat HS comm online
Nations Cup
[Music]